these women are not innocent as we saw
today come out phone records of them
plotting together how to best extract
resources why is the CCTV footage not
included why are there all these leaks
coming out why are they being held such
an extended period of time without
charges Romanian law is remain in law if
you have evidence why would you not
charge somebody everyone who looks at
the case File the maze that they're even
detained in the first place that's from
the professionals the take Brothers will
get out unless there's some amazing new
fine which there won't be there'll be a
trial hopefully sooner rather than later
they will win that is inshallah that is
the end State I've been around this man
for hundreds of days I know professional
has been trained in meeting people I
think I would know if it was some oddly
exploitative criminal he's lived in my
house I'm in his house I'm on the boats
I'm on the Jets I've never once seen him
act in a way that matches any of these
allegations imagine if every person on
this planet felt accountable to a higher
Force we wouldn't have crime tell me
that doesn't result in a much better
Society
assalamualaikum welcome back to the
realest podcast in the Donya the four
Muslims
all right so we are joined today with
the man himself the sartorial shooter
it's a pleasure to be with you here in
Dubai alhamdulillah where he was
gracious enough to invite us to his home
to record this alhamdulillah and uh in
the beautiful city as well alhamdulillah
so first and foremost who is sartorial
shooter all right cool so my name is
Jewel originally from Australia but I
definitely think I'm more than half Arab
by now 15 years in the Middle East I
started my career in the military I was
a soldier
from that I learned a few relevant
languages to this part of the world so I
speak Farsi in Arabic wow although my
Arabic isn't as good as it should be
yeah
but I need to practice more and I will
inshallah having recently reverted to
Islam I'm angry at myself for my Arabic
Heaven having gotten so weak wow so I
remember just just in that Masjid across
the road from my house
two days ago last genre the local Shake
was was speaking with real intent and I
could tell what he was saying was
important but I couldn't understand it I
got very angry with myself so inshallah
give me six months the Arabic will be up
and running again
that's amazing so we do want to know a
little bit more about your past but
before we get into that a lot of people
know you through relation from Andrew
Tate they know your mutuals with him and
a lot of them think like you're you know
his manager or whatever so what is your
relationship with Andrew and how do you
meet him okay so anyone who knows Andrew
Tate knows that you don't manage Andrew
Tate not his manager he doesn't have a
manager he manages himself so I've been
close friends with Andrew and Tristan
for I'd say four maybe five years wow
and I think it's it's fair to say
outside of their their family I'm the
one who had the privilege and I do view
it as very much a privilege of spending
the most time with them face to face so
back before Andrew was too big to live
in a house like this with fans coming
and knocking on the door he used to live
here when he was in Dubai and I've spent
time with his uh his setup in Romania as
well and we've traveled together
extensively all around the world myself
and the Tates all right so yeah I know I
know them very well alhamdulillah so was
there any kind of transition when he he
did blow up
I mean it's been a gradual thing
um but Andrew Tate is is definitely a
very different man now than when I first
met him back when I met him in in 20
I think it was 2018
the main focus was getting money getting
status being a g so to speak yeah as he
became more prominent and more
influential he became a lot more aware
of what he was saying and the fact that
his his he wasn't speaking to you know a
couple of thousand guys on the internet
it became a global phenomenon so he
definitely matured as a result he became
a lot more conscious of what he was
saying and the potential impact of what
he was saying yeah and you'll see if you
look at his final the final message on
Rumble that's the current Andrew Tate
very mature very logical very rational
very aware of his impact yeah the issue
that we have today is everyone's
referencing things years ago saying oh
what a bad man he is yeah that was when
he had 10 000 followers yeah now that he
has millions the attention of the world
he's a lot more aware of the duty that
he has to put forward a very positive
message and that's one of his key
focuses now absolutely and how has being
a Muslim you know shifted that for him
well there's no drinking for one which
I'm all for alhamdulillah I really mean
that uh our man Tristan likes a drink
and we're all very competitive as men so
I mean as you've seen from some of the
footage there was a lot of drinking
Andrew stopped drinking completely no
not us no not a single drink not a
single drink man and I know I'm with him
on the Jets I'm with him you know we
travel together not not a single drink
which I think is great now but also
anything he does he wants to do it
properly you know that mindset of
professionalism uh enough commitment so
that I'd say that's the first big change
um secondly he is a genuine I I think a
bit of an inner peace thing coming
through which I haven't seen before he's
a very driven man there's a lot of you
know Focus to to conquer and to and we
can talk about that more I think his his
reversion to Islam has brought more of
an inner peace than I've seen in him
before which I think is is quite a
beautiful thing wow wow absolutely and I
think I think we can all say that we've
seen it in his recent videos as well you
know even the way he talks to people
like Eden Ross you know motivating them
even from an Islamic perspective you
know kind of giving down to them in a
way it's a beautiful thing to see but on
the top of on the topic of Andrew Tate
how was he doing in the case if you
don't mind speaking about that no it's
100 very happy to
um so the thing with with Andrew a lot
of people don't understand is he's lived
a very challenging life and I think it's
great that people are concerned for his
welfare but he's Rock Solid he and his
brother uh
two of the most mentally disciplined
people I've come across they're very
strong-minded this is just another in in
a lifetime of obstacles again these guys
were so hungry at one point they were
going to KFC to take out the left in the
in the Box chicken freeze it at home and
then unfreeze that over the weeks to
come to to sustain themselves while they
were fighting wow and you're going into
the ring when you can't even feed
yourself properly that's where these
guys came from so to put in perspective
yes this is unjust yes this is
wrong on many levels but as brothers in
terms of their mindset they're Rock
Solid they also know what they have and
haven't done they know that these
charges are nonsense they know that that
will come out and so that to be honest
they're in good good spirits yeah
they're fine do you think do you think
Andrew Ted being a Muslim is helping him
with his confidence now definitely
definitely definitely I know that one of
the the few books he has access to is
the Quran and knowing him he'll be
devouring that that's he needs something
he doesn't have a phone he doesn't have
you know his usual work I I I'm willing
to bet that he's spending a lot of time
reading and I one of the things I I give
dollar for that I pray for every day in
the mosque I'm trying to get to Masjid
every day is that this experience brings
him closer to a faith that that is is
lasting and is real and I believe that's
happening
I mean I mean so if you don't mind
talking about some of the details around
the case I've heard a lot that there is
a lack of evidence even his lawyer went
on record saying there's no evidence at
all uh Tristan Tate came out you know
saying to the reporters ask for the
evidence ask the judge you know why
they're doing this and that where is the
evidence and you know all these people
pull out these statements random
statements here and there from videos
throughout his past and my question is
you know if these statements are so
Grand and so obvious that he did
whatever they're claiming he did either
why have they not been admitted as into
the evidence or why do people keep
saying there's no evidence at all
um so first of all I'm not I'm not
officially uh you know authorized to
represent him
um I'm his friend I'm not his manager
some people would say yeah um also I I
can't speak on behalf of the lawyers but
as as his friend who's watching what's
happening and having been in Tate's
house and spent time there yeah the way
I would answer that was would be to
apply basic logic
so there's CCTV in and outside of his
house I've seen the system I'm a
security professional I looked at you
know we did a bit of a review it's a
pretty good system
why isn't that being used in court
that's one two
this is a famous and wealthy man with a
lot of influence
is it really that rare or that unique to
have false allegations against famous
men with wealth with influence third if
we look at and again I don't want to say
anything that I shouldn't legally but if
we look at the source of these
complaints as I understand it they're
not from the most it initially for
example there was this narrative that oh
these are innocent women who have been
taken from the village and they've been
exploited if you look into this details
these women are far from poor
Village girls they're women who were
working as you know in that industry
which I think is is Haram and I don't
have anything to do with it but they
were working in
like strippers or only fans these sorts
of things prior
um they they have been known to be
it's very difficult to talk about these
women are not innocent yeah and also as
we saw today come out there's phone
records of them plotting together as to
how to best extract resources and and
essentially do what is quite predictable
yeah certain and again I don't think
this is a gender thing we don't need to
gender it certain
levels of people will do anything they
can to get ahead in life even if it
means ruining someone else's life
I believe it's a lot more logical
to assess that we have some people using
nefarious tactics to get resources or
attention or whatever the agenda is I
think that's a lot more realistic than
someone who's very wealthy having to
exploit someone for a small amount of
money yeah when you were driving a
Bugatti and flying private jets
logically do you have the time or the
attention to try and exploit someone for
low levels of money again so yes there's
a lot of people saying there's no
evidence but on top of that
there's no logic being applied here and
if we look at the other side
we know that he's very influential we
know that many different people with
significant power would like him to shut
up and stop empowering men stop speaking
Pro Traditional Values perhaps stop
representing and and bringing attention
to Islam
isn't it a logical conclusion that
perhaps there's an agenda here yeah and
again I'm not a lawyer but we can see
with some of the tactics that are
happening why is the CCTV footage not
included why are there all these leaks
coming out yeah you know why are they
being held for such an extended period
of time without charges yeah I
understand Romanian lawyers remaining
law I I don't you know I'm not going to
criticize a legal system I'm not a
lawyer but on a logical ethical human
level if you have evidence why would you
not charge somebody these things for me
as a layperson as a non-legal
professional they don't add up so that'd
be my response to your question what it
seems to be is these two women decided
and and kind of applied it to accuse him
of whatever and as you mentioned there
were the records from the WhatsApp chat
that were leaked between them and
between one of them and their family
literally conspiring to lie and this
these conversations took place a day or
two days before the case was opened up
against him which was back in April last
year so everyone on saying this has been
an ongoing investigation it's been going
on since April it seems to be the case
that this whole thing started with these
conversations false allegations and them
conspiring to lie against them and then
this went on for since last April up
until today he's been in Romania he's
lived there for a long time he recently
moved out and he just went back for a
visit and they got him because of a
pizza box at his at his crib basically
and you know we're expected to take that
wholeheartedly and not question it at
all I think that's that's very very
flawed it's remarkable how many people
will accept any narrative that's fed to
them yeah the the the Sheep really are
asleep nowadays it's quite remarkable so
obviously the pizza box thing is
ridiculous Romanian government would
know when someone comes into their
country it's a little thing called
passport control you don't need a pizza
box
um but yeah to your point I think the
the fact that this has been an open
investigation since April of last year
what are we nine months 10 months and
you still don't have enough to charge
somebody but you're gonna
strip them of their Liberty of their
freedom of movement to me that's pretty
unethical again I'm not a legal
professional but I see a lot of I mean I
thought the the haters the the
essentially the Liberals the left were
pro-human rights Pro these things what
if someone you don't like is imprisoned
for months then it doesn't matter human
rights don't matter yeah absolutely and
that's one of the biggest flaws on their
side they they will always argue for
freedom of speech freedom of belief
freedom of sexuality freedom of any
regard until it's with someone they
don't like I literally my friend Orlando
on tiktok he pulls very controversial
content they literally put a petition
you know death penalty for him and it's
like where did your liberal values go
like maybe it started as a joke but you
know that's not a funny thing to joke
about to me it's it's a modern day
version of the Gestapo you know if you
commit a thought crime you're no longer
a citizen you need to be thrown in the
gulag but it's a virtual gestapo oh
you've said something against our
narrative therefore you don't have any
rights and we're going to cancel you and
get you off all platforms I had that
happen to me I was I was doxed I had
people harassing uh you know known
associates my former employer all these
different things my one day I couldn't
log into my Twitter which I still can't
I had shahada there as my bio that was
taken away all these things and and all
these strange and very weak false
allegations made against me
if you want to come after people like
Andrew I get that he said a lot of wild
things I'm a pretty boring professional
like you're going to come after me with
all these false allegations and now it's
on record so
you can slander somebody's name without
any real basis but these haters These
these liberal activists they still think
they're the good guys it's remarkable
yeah I'm a very caring uh father I'm a a
very respectable professional I try to
bring the value I can to society I give
zakat I gave us a cut even before I
became Muslim as as and I don't need to
advertise it I do it you know it's
there's a it's a bit of a selfish thing
to give it gives you satisfaction right
yeah what are these haters done for
society how many how many you know what
what are they doing for their their
Community what donations are they giving
to help you know the earthquake victims
in in Turkey these people are toxic but
they walk around thinking they're doing
something good I've really really and to
be honest I'm happy I'm not on Twitter
because what a cesspool of negativity
yeah these people need the real world
they need Faith all these Tate haters
they need
faith in their life that they've lost
touch with God they're overly attached
with Donya you know their very their
mindset is all very toxic I I reckon it
might sound a bit sort of cheeky those
who are hating on Tate who are coming
after Tate I think Islam would solve a
lot of their problems I genuinely mean
that I think if they were you know five
times a day Salah if and reminding
themselves of what matters and what
doesn't in life they wouldn't be
consumed with all this negativity
focused on on Tate someone they don't
even know making all these assumptions
and allegations about something someone
they don't even know I've been around
this man for hundreds of days yeah
I'm I'm a professional who's been
trained in in reading people I think I
would know if he was some wildly
exploitative criminal you know he's
lived in my house yet these people have
never even met him feel they have the
conviction or the investigative ability
to completely slander his name and
present their weak assumptions as facts
yeah disgusting State of Affairs yeah
and it's funny it's funny because
everyone you're not the only one
everyone who has actually met him that
I've seen has said nothing but good
things about him and I've even more than
met him I've seen him interacting with
women yeah I'm on I'm on I'm in his
house he's in my house I'm on the boats
I'm on the Jets yeah I have never once
seen him act in a way that matches any
of these allegations you have all these
haters who've already made up their mind
as to his character and his actions
okay so if we're going to take
everything literally we need to go and
arrest every gangster rapper you know a
bus a cat all right they need to go to
jail yeah we need we need to arrest
every WWF bad guy you know I'm gonna
find you I'm going to kill you oh we
better arrest them he used controversial
comments to break the internet and
become famous it worked so now we're
going to pretend everything he says is
literal it's there's a lot of holes in
the arguments of the haters let's put it
that way absolutely but speaking about
converting to Islam jaw we want to know
about your story if you're born into you
know whatever religion you can talk
about that if you want to talk about
that how you came into Islam but I want
to know your life before Islam
spiritually Okay cool so 13 years of
Catholic schooling I'll be honest church
was always a chore we used to I remember
we used to hide so we didn't have to go
to church in school
but it was it was presented as a chore
and it was always a very boring very
dull thing
having moved to the Middle East I've
been here for 15 years I've lived in
Iran Syria a lot of time in Saudi Iraq
and so on I always felt that
especially when I'd see people rushing
to the Masjid for choma prayer I I'd
felt they've got something I don't not
in an envious thing but just seeing you
know I see that they have a devotion and
a Brotherhood and a faith a connection
with God which I don't I always felt
something was missing in that sense but
ultimately my decision to revert I mean
it was a long time coming I was
I'd say pretty serious about my reading
for the last five years because it's not
it's not a small decision right and
there's no going back once it's done it
was not an emotional thing
um it was purely logical
and my reasoning being that first of all
if you want to get the most out of The
Human Experience why would you live
without a connection to God you know if
you if you want
to perceive Humanity with a certain
system that made you the most worthwhile
human you could be
you know to live out your Human
Experience in the best way possible to
therefore contribute the most to
humanity to your family to society and
so on
why not Islam because for me it's a lot
more than just a religion in in the
sense that to answer your question
pre-islam I thought religion was go to
church once a week
you know say a few things
understanding Islam to me it's it's so
much more than what I perceived a
religion to be before it's a system for
perceiving the world it's a system for
self-programming yourself effectively
what are you doing when you when you
pray you're giving gratitude you're
acknowledging that you are not you know
the center of the universe you're
conceptualizing things like shaytan you
know Temptation you're conceptualizing
the fact that you are accountable to a
higher Force
how does that not make you a better
human and therefore better positioned to
give value to your family to stay
disciplined to work hard for society to
me it's just in a purely logical sense
Islam is a system that makes you the
best version you can be when practiced
earnestly and therefore makes you the
most positive contributor to your family
unit to your brothers to society
how can you argue against that to me
it's overwhelmingly positive so that was
the turning point if for me personally
my main goal in life at the moment is to
be the best version of the man I can be
Islam is a is a a real accelerator of
that it really is it's a system for life
to make you the best version of a man
that you can be and I think that's I
think it's quite powerful So speaking
about connection tool guide have you
ever dealt with atheism because a lot of
people I hear this a lot I'm too logical
for God I'm too rational to believe in a
God to that I'd say atheists to me first
of all don't seem like very happy people
so that that's the first one
um but secondly okay the argument for or
against God again what's your primary
purpose for being on this planet if it's
to be the best version of a man that you
can be and give the most positive impact
to your family your brothers the causes
you believe in society
then trying to do that without it
without religion without Islam you're
missing you're missing a a weapon in
Your Arsenal so atheists to me they're
shooting themselves in the foot let's
say you know somehow they are right
which obviously we know they're not
if their belief systems don't make them
fulfilled and make them the best
versions of themselves they can be then
what's the point of their belief system
I I I would argue that logic
if you're if you can go to a mosque and
feel an intense emotional connection
with a higher power feel the Brotherhood
or the the men you're standing next to
why would you choose atheism where you
miss out on all these things to me
that's illogical so that would be my
argument there
so
how would you say that Islam has changed
life
or benefit each of that yeah interesting
one brother I mean it hasn't been that
long
um
I feel
a lot of energy about my desire to learn
more which I quite like
um
typically learning new things can be a
bit of a chore whereas the more I read
about Islam the more the conversations I
have the more hunger I have to learn so
I feel even more motivated I'm a pretty
motivated guy already like I work pretty
hard I feel more motivated to carve out
more time to to increase my learning
definitely going to the Masjid is I try
and go every day I've I've been
successful by one day in the last couple
weeks
there's a there's a power there which I
haven't really comprehended yet
um and I I think it's simply by I mean
the phrase Allahu Akbar God is is the
biggest the greatest just by
acknowledging that and giving thanks to
me it gets your ego out of the way it
gets your problems out of the way and
yes you could say you know I'm grateful
to God for everything I've been given
you go to a Masjid and you pray that's
an action and we all know actions have
more power than words so for me I mean
one example ever since my kids were
really little before we go to bed we
always take turns saying three things
we're grateful for throughout the day
because I wanted to build that mindset
in my in my kids to be grateful
especially because growing up in in
Dubai alhamdulillah they have everything
they could ever want I wanted them to
stay stay grounded and stay grateful
tell me that going and praying isn't the
adult version of that you are
self-programming you yourself to be
grateful you are reminding yourself that
there is a higher power that you are
accountable to that higher power so
through that practice I've become even
more grateful and even more focused on
each getting the most out of each day I
I find that the the ritual of prayer
definitely adds discipline you need to
get up you know but by certain times you
know you need to I need to learn Arabic
to understand what I'm saying better
it's as a whole it's very motivating
it's given me a lot more energy uh to
approach every day yeah and how long
have you actually been Muslim so I
actually took shahada when I was in
Philippines because I got sick of
waiting it was just I was in a bathroom
in the Philippines but officially
um in in this Masjid behind us about I'd
say 10 days ago
um and one was Philippines if you don't
mind me Philippines was a couple weeks
back uh through three weeks ago okay I
just a friend of mine who was chatting
with he said you know you can do it now
you don't have to wait to be in a Masjid
so I was just like all right let's go
there's this innate believe that I have
that we become Muslim before we become
Muslim like you know you're a Muslim and
you take the shahada subconsciously
before you logically come to terms with
verbalizing the shadow because I think
that's your ego catching up with what
you innately believe when you already
submit that
correlates with my experience 100 100
the one thing I will say that surprised
me a lot about Islam is the amount of
emotion involved Islam is a very
masculine frame with which to approach
life Traditional Values are enforced a
man has to protect a man has to provide
you know if you have the blessing of
means then you should give back to the
community to me it's a very masculine
mindset to apply to life but also the
amount of emotion involved when I took
shahada the Sheikh he cried and he's a
serious guy he's a masculine guy yeah
he's the sort of guy you want to be
polite to but he shed a tear is it to
see such a masculine man you know
brought to that emotion is magical I
think it's very rare and then often in
the Masjid people are crying I had no
idea I had one guy next to me once he
was quivering with emotion that's how
powerful it is so
see and everyone's talking about the
heart everybody talks about the heart
about the softness of the heart I've had
about four or five uh very well read
Muslim men say you have a very soft
heart you are open to Islam you'll do
well I'm like why are all these very
strong masculine men talking about the
heart it's quite an interesting thing so
that's been a real learning for me too I
think
the the
type of masculinity that I see in Muslim
men who are take their faith seriously
is a very rounded masculinity yes you
take care of your family yes it's your
duty to be strong and and to be able to
defend and provide but at the same time
you can shed a tear when talking about
your relationship with God you can feel
emotion and and that's not frowned upon
and everyone's talking about the heart
as I mentioned I think it's a very
beautiful thing you've got very
masculine men who are also in a healthy
way in touch with
emotion through their relationship with
God what a fantastically rounded way to
be a man in today's day and age where
we're being told all these different
forms of of being a man are the right
way I think the Islamic you know
approach to being a man is is the most
effective I really believe that so
that's been a real learning and
Improvement in in terms of value add to
my life as well man yeah there's um this
is one Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad
he says that there's a piece of Flesh
within the body that if it's pure then
verily is the rest and speaking about
the heart and then you're saying Allah
it's so interesting why why is everybody
in Islam speaking about the heart you
know self the heart itself why are these
guys with big masculine beards talking
about the Hutt yeah masculine guys yeah
I feel a bit of beard Envy bro I need to
catch up with you
[Laughter]
it's funny my uh my barber is is a
Muslim guy and every time I ask him to
trim my beard he's like um I don't know
if we should
yeah it'll grow on each other so I
didn't mean to interact yeah no you so
what I want to say is that
this is Hadith and the prophet keeps me
upon him he's he's highlighting this and
then when you're looking at Islam you
have these you haven't been you're
actual men and they're speaking about
that softness and and it's not it's not
a quality that men uh would inherently
possess it's something that's it's
almost like uh enforced on us
by Allah interesting because the the
Quran is um the Quran is very powerful
it's the words of Allah and I'm speaking
to the brothers in the car about this
but the Quran when you hear recitation
it doesn't matter whether you're a
Muslim or whether you say you're not
Muslim
it literally grabs you and it starts
shaking you and it makes you let go and
emotions start coming up you don't even
know why like you're feeling these
emotions you know so it's subhanallah
like it's it's a law that softens us as
men but it's that softening that makes
us even more masculine Interesting Man
interesting I like it I see a lot of
value the more I learn about
you know the Quran and and all of the
associated literature and a lot of
conversations the more I feel hang on
those are the values I try to live by
like I've independently to your point
becoming a Muslim before you're Muslim
I've built a code that I hold myself to
in life and as do my brother's main a
circle and then I see it represented in
a book that's
centuries old it's like oh hang on
there's power here there's truth here if
every man I know is either a practice
who I fully respect is either a
practicing Muslim
or carries himself with a very similar
code if not the same code to a
practicing Muslim without identifying as
Muslim there's some power there there's
some truth there I really I really see
that more and more
obviously there's lifestyle changes when
you convert or revert to Islam for me
cutting out the alcohol is a blessing
I'm fine cutting you out the Hedonism
that's why I'm 40 years old I've had
enough Hedonism for one lifetime if you
get to 40 and you're still chasing
hedonism
you haven't lived enough you know that
there's nothing there the Hedonism does
not bring you fulfillment I've learned
that through Human Experience what
really hurt me hurt I mean
what what I felt some emotion about was
selling my gold watches
yeah because I mean for me as someone
who grew up rough um I I didn't even see
a Rolex till I was you know late 20s
um times were tough growing up always
secondhand clothing you know we've all
had our struggles but
having
um being that man who was self-made
watches were always a symbol for me of
success and I love my Rolexes I love my
collection I had to sell a bunch of
pieces I was humming and owing because
some people are saying it is Haram it's
not Haram but then a friend of mine who
I respect who actually was the one who
told me the ablutions uh I won't mention
him by name because he's a bit of a high
profile guy but he knows who he is thank
you brother
um he said one line to me he said look
man you can argue whether it's Haram or
halal
but really what would you be wearing
gold that's for women I was like oh man
he's got me there no because he's got me
there's an adornment it isn't adornment
bro it's beautifying yourself exactly so
I was thinking and he's like why would
you be wearing jewelry that is you know
looks looks better on women and that was
I was like okay you got me now as an
Aussie if you're gonna question my
masculinity it's definitely done so I
had to I had to sell a bunch of watches
I did it pretty much straight away
because at the end of the day
if we are holding ourselves to account
to be the best men we can be then that
means anything that detracts from that
why are we doing it and that that was my
reasoning there and then at that point I
no longer was so regretful about having
to sell my gold watches wow wow that's
beautifully said you know actually it
reminds me of a Hadith of one of the
companions of the Prophet Muhammad peace
upon him he said take yourself to
account before you take into account or
hold yourself accountable before you're
held accountable I like that that's
beautiful and that's one of the things
I've really been talking about a lot
imagine if every person on this planet
felt accountable to a higher Force we
wouldn't have crime we'd have a very
compassionate Society if everybody
believed in Judgment Day if everybody
believed every one of their actions were
being noted and and witnessed by a you
know the Creator tell me that doesn't
result in a much better Society
absolutely even even like the founder of
liberalism John Locke he said you can't
trust atheists because they have no
morality nothing objective you know so
if someone who lived that long ago who
founded liberalism which is what you
know Western Society is based on
nowadays he says that then how are
Muslims you know not at least 10 steps
ahead of him in that regard exactly and
and that was to go back to an earlier
question as to what brought me to Islam
I realized all of the men who I really
truly respect uh Muslims who take their
faith seriously I just kept noticing
that you know that's a guy who I could
trust you know my children to if I
needed to who I could give my my net
worth to and not be worried so to that
point if we all held ourselves to that
that sense of accountability to me
that's a powerful way to to hold to make
to force yourself to be the best version
of a man you can be yeah it's very
powerful that's beautiful because that's
literally exactly and I was telling you
this before that you described Islam in
a way that a lot of people Unfortunately
they just don't understand it to be
right Islam is something that is meant
to be implemented you know calling
people to Islam is not just it's not
just teaching them about you know what
we believe it's getting them to enjoin
the good and forbid the evil you know
you you enjoin on yourself and others
that which is good that which is
beneficial and you forbid on yourself
and others that which is evil you know
that which leads to the regress or
degeneracy in society now that's exactly
what Islam is something that's supposed
to be implemented into your life by
yourself and by society as a whole a
system if you will to live life not not
just words exactly I like that and I
mean without getting too sort of deep
about it I genuinely believe Islam is
the only solution to deal with shaytan I
think when we look at the way liberalism
has taken over the west and we see all
sorts of agendas even being pushed on
young innocent minds of children Islam
is the only defense that we have against
that and so for me people who are not
actively looking into Islam or who
haven't you know reverted yet inshallah
they're not reading the chessboard of
Life properly because if you look at the
State of Affairs what's what is the
solution to the so-called Progressive
liberal degeneracy we see being spread
throughout Society the the men no longer
feeling the need to protect and provide
where have all the good men gone the
women who no longer realize that
having sex with many strangers is going
to damage you like it's to me the way
Western Society has gone I think it's
lost to shaitan and that's why I think
Islam is literally the only solution to
deal with that that damage that we're
seeing in the west yeah and I meant I
mean again like it's amazing that you
mentioned that because Islam you said
it's a system right the word Deen which
is usually translates religion it's not
just religion you know religion is more
so like something like Christianity just
religion a Deen is a full way of life
interesting I didn't know that it's
something that a person is supposed to
you know
completely subscribed to in life right
and this whole Talk of the Matrix The
Matrix people think it's some sci-fi
thing I think the Matrix is is a really
good way to dumb down what it what the
Deep state is you know to a lot of
layman the Deep state is what like the
the deeper level to the government the
people who really call the shots make
the agenda write the rules and then you
know the politicians everyone else is
just the face of that like don't you
find it remarkable that no matter who
you elect in office nothing really
changes you know it's been so long of
electing you know uh Trudeau than
someone else and someone else in Trudeau
or you know Clinton Bush Obama nothing
changed people thought Obama Obama was
amazing he bombed the Middle East like
nobody else at one point he was bombing
seven countries all of whom were in the
I think the
the category of the world's most
desperately poor countries how many how
many Americans were aware of where the
tax paying dollars were going yeah and
we gave this man a Nobel Peace Prize
again I don't want to get too deep into
politics yeah I think there are much
more important things to focus on in
life but tell me that's that's not a
form of evil man yeah the the most
wealthy country in the world routinely
bombing the most poorest countries in
the world
that that makes me sad on a very deep
level yeah it does and it's an atrocious
thing but if you look at you know the
life of the Prophet peace upon him and
Islam and this is something me and the
brothers you know discussed extensively
alhamdulillah Islam is not just a
solution for every individual is Islam
is a solution for Western problems Islam
is a solution for all of life and Islam
is what will break the Matrix right
Andrew Tate talks a lot about breaking
the Matrix and all that stuff and
something I really want to discuss with
them is you're breaking them out of the
Matrix but what are you putting them
into you can't just bring people out of
something very valid question yeah and
not have an alternative Islam is the
alternative if you look at the life the
prophet peace and blessings be upon him
he came to to contest The Matrix he came
to con to you know contest the people at
on the top these people had you know
pilgrims essentially from all over
Arabia come to worship statues and idols
and they would pay them to do that so
when you have this man peace blessed be
upon him come and he's like these Idols
are nothing you should not pay money to
worship let me shall worship them at all
actually we should destroy all them and
worship the one Creator and you can do
that for free right and he's trying to
equalize even the rich and the poor in
the same level you know not not in terms
of money but in terms of you know their
worth and their value in society and in
the eyes of God they didn't like that if
Prophet Muhammad Allah had an Instagram
page he would have been canceled hard oh
yeah 100 of course but to your point I
really like that I love let's present
that to Titan I think that'd be great if
you break people out of the Matrix what
do you give them because humans need
Dogma I mean it's there's only so many
Alphas that can exist in in a tribe most
people are designed to be followers
right and so we're either going to get
that dog where that guidance on how to
live from
religion or from government like
Communist States you know that the party
should be worshiped or from culture and
nowadays modern day culture is
it's it's degenerate it's ABS it's an
anti-family it's anti uh men being
traditional looking after those they
care about you know it's anti-women
looking after themselves like it's
modern day culture is such a terrible
place to find that Dogma that that
guidance for Life yeah that yeah that's
a good point once you break people out
of the Matrix what do you give them yeah
and I think again the answer is I see no
other answer than Islam absolutely it
makes you wonder if everyone's so
liberated why are they not happy that's
it or you can see there's a direct
correlation between the more free and
liberal a country is and the higher
divorce rates when we have divorce rates
we have single parent families and
statistics clearly show all the issues
that come from single parent families
more likely to end up in jail more
likely to die at an early age more
likely to have learning issues as
children and then then also I've done a
lot of reading on this there's a direct
correlation between the more liberal a
country is and the the more people live
not use but live on antidepressants wow
again do we really want to pretend that
this progresses Progressive
progressivism this modernity is making
people happy if if you want to say that
living on antidepressants is happy then
sure that's what it's achieving but for
me and I said this in the vice
documentary and I believe they tried to
frame it as me being misogynistic the
happiest people I I know are the men and
women who are in relationships that
adhere to traditional Dynamics yeah now
yes a woman can do whatever she wants a
man can do whatever he wants the point I
was making is from my lived experience
the most fulfilled relationships are
where the man is doing that which is
traditionally you know done you know the
actions traditionally done by the man
and the woman is doing that which is
traditionally done by the woman yeah now
again any woman any man can do whatever
they want but for maximum fulfillment
I'd love to see a counter argument to
the fact that those adhering to
traditional Dynamics traditional
relationship Dynamics traditional gender
roles
I see again and again they're the ones
who are the most fulfilled in life yeah
and they're the ones who are giving the
most back to society they're the ones
who are most high output most productive
so this I I'm yet to see anyone really
be a great example of I'm following
liberalism I'm following modernity I
identify as a Coke can I'm yet to see
them be really happy and fulfilled in
life I just see a bunch of issues and
I'll be surprised if you're a child and
you're told hey wait a sec you can be a
this or that a man or a woman of course
you're going to be confused and they're
a psychologist even in Sweden coming out
saying this is damaging for kids yeah so
I I really think
whether it's conscious or unconscious I
think that's the work of shaytan I think
it is society destroying evil and again
the only viable answer is Islam yeah 100
I'm every every Avenue of Western
Society nowadays is com is a complete
fight against Islam you know you can
honestly summarize in a few sentences
liberalism is their Deen it's their
religion it's their way and the wokism
is the new religion exactly and their
God is are their desires literally
because a God is anything you obey
that's what Allah says in the Quran have
you seen the one or yes have you seen
the person who takes their own desires
as their God because uh we were talking
about this before ibad the worship a big
part of that is who do you obey so if
you're a desire say oh I want this I
want women I want to eat that I want to
go there I want to you desire that and
you do it that's basically like God
telling you go do this and you're going
and listening no matter what because
that's what you obey above everything
else and liberalism is there a way you
know do whatever you want as long as
you're not harming other people even if
you harm yourself go chase your own
Pleasures that's exactly what what
they're taught to do and it's exactly
what they do that's wow too and then you
see platforms like Vice pushing
pedophilia pushing drug use man they
push drug use so much what benefit is
this to society by pushing the youth
into drugs tell me that's not evil again
I'm not a conspiracy theorist I don't
buy into the whole new world order but
what I see with my own eyes is leftist
Media houses left us documentary makers
pushing this decrepit rubbish onto the
minds of the youth I think it's really
damaging I think it's disgusting and
they'll claim the opposite bro they'll
claim that you know what it's not a
religion I don't look at it as a God I'm
not worshiping it but then what are they
doing you dare speak against it they'll
wage shihad against you
the cancellation thing is real it's
amazing man so let's talk about that a
bit so the whole Matrix cancellation or
attempt I should say right because I
think the elderly failed completely but
their whole attempt where do you think
this stemmed from I don't think there's
a bunch of big bad leftists sitting
around in a room
calculating how to destroy masculinity
or destroy the family unit I do think
there are certain narratives that take
on and this spread like wildfire now if
I was a leader of a country would I want
a bunch of free thinking strong banded
together brothers that's a bit
threatening isn't it
however if I had these weak men who
essentially being owned by their wives
disrespected by their children too
unhappy to really rise up that you could
argue that's a good thing if your goal
is to control the masses
so I think at the end of the day
the less masculine a population is the
easier it is to control so I think many
leaders around the world perhaps have
bought into this anti-masculinity drive
simply because of control reasons and
again I don't think it's some globally
orchestrated new world order as far as
my opinion but I just think certain
narratives benefit those who are in
power and say for example if you destroy
the family unit if you take away
religion from people's lives where are
you going to look for for guidance you
want to look for to look to the
government look to culture which can be
influenced by you know the power players
of the world so to me this is all about
control that's all it is there's a lot
more of the masses than there are of you
know the rulers why not make the people
as sheepish and as lost and as easily
controlled as possible that's why I see
that's what I see driving the assault on
you know masculine values on Traditional
Values on on religion see that's the
same thing we're trying to do like
brother Rami said we're trying to
replace this whole Matrix and
brainwashing with Islam but the system
is doing the opposite they're like 10
steps ahead 100 subset they replaced
religion with the system with a new type
of religion yeah I don't think you can
ever beat
um wokism I think
when the left controls the information
flow Instagram Hollywood you know
mainstream media how are you going to
compete against that the only way to do
it to me is
by those who are open who have that soft
heart to Islam finding Islam and holding
themselves to a different set of morals
holding themselves to a different level
of accountability instead of trying to
please the the woke Gods by putting
their bio in their Twitter handle they
need to please Allah
which is which is a lot deeper and a lot
more meaningful and a lot bigger value
add to society I saw an amazing study
that that checked the amount of actual
charity work done by liberals compared
to those that charity done by
conservatives conservatives give so much
more so again these and that was that
was in America these liberals walking
around thinking they're doing something
by just basically hating on anyone who
doesn't spread their narrative they're
not actually benefiting Society they're
not doing anything of value other than
spreading negativity
Okay so
with Andrew Tate yeah
we see that he's uh very on top of
everything and uh yeah yeah he said many
times like that he only eats like at the
end of the day stuff like this and you
mentioned earlier that he's literally
working all day long constantly I'd love
to use the training as well I'd love to
talk to them yeah yeah so and then we
mentioned as well that you you said he
has an iron mind and I asked you what is
an Iron Man why don't you go into that
okay so
the iron mine as far as I perceive it is
just a singular undying focus on on
conquest and and Conquest in terms of
Tate's life is
obviously making money is one metric
um having success in all worldly Realms
learning you know constantly exercising
the brain the body
every day Tate wakes up and he's almost
angry at himself for having Not
Conquered yet not achieved not learned
not evolved as a man
and so he literally will not eat because
that's when his mind's most clear and he
can most you know his output is highest
until he's made a certain amount of
money or or you know achieve a certain
amount of learning it had his his
Conquest for the day then he'll allow
himself to eat five or six o'clock and
he doesn't eat much he keeps himself
hungry because that's when he's most
optimal his whole thing in life is how
can I be the most high output man I can
be so and examples for example when
we're on the yacht in Croatia we flew in
one of the world's best drone Pilots the
acts are incredible work we had a super
yacht hundreds of thousands of Euros a
week jet skis I hate to say hey Tate do
you want to stop working and we'll get
some footage on the jet skis he shuts
the laptop oh I guess we should we you
know Buzz around our laptop for 20
minutes he's back on the laptop like
that man lives to work that's all he
cares about so yes he attained Global
Fame because of controversial comments
and you know playing that that he
understands how to how to bring in
attention how to monetize attention he's
mastered that but also he works
constantly more than any man I've ever
seen he's so driven so to tie into that
I'd say iron mind is that singular Focus
every day he doesn't do weekends in the
hundreds of days I've spent around him
I've never seen him chill and watch a
movie I've never he doesn't do holidays
it's on every day without exception and
he's training as well he'll hit the same
muscle group every day for 10 days in a
row it's just different it's
he's operating on a level of output and
and hence an energetic frequency that's
higher above any man I've ever seen and
how is that possible so one is is
naturally very intelligent very driven
but he also surrounds himself with with
other men so there's that masculine
accountability he and his brother very
competitive I I try and get in the mix a
bit myself I remember when I started
first rolling with the Tates I'd need
like a week off to recover when I was
around them because training constantly
there was a lot of hard drinking very
little sleep you know smashing cars
around mountains uh constant push
constant Conquest constant work I'd be
exhausted but nowadays when I'm around
the guys I have the same energy that's
that same frequency that same high
output I also fast all day and eat and
eat when the work is done so it's it's
it's like a muscle you can develop being
that super high energy high output high
frequency man with other high output men
around you you your boy drops and does
push-ups in between you know typing away
you're not going to not do it
your boy doesn't sleep for hours because
he's working constantly you're not going
to say oh I'm going to bed while he's
working that sense of masculine
accountability which which Andrew and
Tristan hold each other to account
that's also a very powerful part of of
living in that masculine frame that
Conquest Focus frame is quite remarkable
to see as I said at first was exhausting
but now I'm there myself I work every
day I train every day
it's why would I especially now that I'm
learning about Islam why would I sit and
watch TV how does that improve improve
my skills in life I could be I could be
taking a chess lesson why would I sit
and play video games when I could be
learning about Islam and about you know
text that are hundreds of years old but
they're still powerful to this day it's
it's this undying energy and motivation
for Daily Progress as a man daily
conquest and that's part of the reason
why Tate's so famous it's not talking
about women or saying you know country
virtual things the reason he has so many
fans is he helps ignite that fire in
other men and women too to be the best
version of that they can be to put in
that endless work every day his various
products as I understand them are
communities where and I'm part of the
worm I definitely understand that one
communities where every man in there is
holding themselves to account did you
really put in your best effort today did
you did you fast so you could maintain
that clear mind so you can go out and
Conquer or did you watch Netflix and eat
ice cream you know like like a good like
a good sheep and that's why you're so
famous it's that motivational message he
is able to take that high output energy
and it can Empower other people to lift
up and have that same Focus that same
drive that same iron mind that's the
real reason why he's famous you won't
hear that in the newspapers you won't
yeah you hear slander like insole he was
born rich he had an easy life I love
that is that is that what someone would
do and you hear it with women too you
hear a misogynist someone that abuses
women but what was your experience with
him interacting with women so again I I
can stay hand on heart I've never once
seen him act in a way that matches these
allegations never once have I seen him
even be rude to a waiter the real Tate
that you interact with is a very polite
individual yes he's on his phone a lot
because he's working and he's focused
but he has never I've never once seen
him be openly disrespectful or nasty
towards anybody that's not who he is and
you hear that from everyone who actually
knows him so yeah I hope that answers
your question but the real Tate is
very logical very intelligent very
respectful
and very very driven again if a man is
that focused on on Conquest on on
becoming the best version of himself why
would he engage in this this low-level
stuff that he's accused of is it what's
more likely a guy with a Bugatti trying
to exploit someone for I don't know what
is it a couple hundred dollars a day or
getting online
bringing in the attention the world and
monetizing that which we know you can do
effectively yeah so and and some some
other things about Titan
I think the best way to put it is that
he is very
he's very firm and he's very principled
but he's also very empathetic a lot of
people try and say he's a narcissist or
he's a uh this or that
spend time with the guy he's very
empathetic he's very respectful he's
very for his brothers he'd do anything
once you were in a circle with Tate he
is extremely caring as a man so all this
idea that he is somehow some nasty guy
hey look let's get specific if two
adults want to engage in sexual acts
that are forceful I mean what is the
most popular book of all time outside of
you know the holy books I hate
mentioning them in the same sentence
Fifty Shades of Gray have you seen that
one of the most successful books of the
last couple of decades it's because a
lot of women are into that sort of thing
now if you're going to engage in that
sort of stuff consensually that's your
business why is that all of a sudden
being used as a pretense to say that
this man is a monster
I mean let's let's be really honest here
the majority of women in the world do
have fantasies that involve BDSM or
Fifty Shades of Gray type activities
that's why the book is so popular we're
going to forget that and say oh wait a
sec Tate strangled a woman during
intimacy
I know Tate he's not going to force that
on somebody I also know women women
enjoy that sort of thing right all of
that is being forgotten in the media all
of a sudden he's just a bad guy I I
thought I thought the left were meant to
be accepting of people's sexual
preferences why are we King shaming tell
me that's not King shaming it's a
textbook every married man had his
conversations with his wife leaked
I'm sure there would be things that they
were deem as forceful or this especially
if you screenshotted just a part of that
conversation not the whole thing again I
mean if we're talking about the dark
side of the left Stalin's head of
Securities was famous for saying show me
the man I'll show you the crime in other
words if we want to look into any
citizen we can find crimes dependent on
him and this is what we're seeing right
here Tate spoke against the agenda
loudly he he became the primary point of
reference for the fighting age males of
the of the world that's a serious amount
of power so let's let's accuse him of
something even if the evidence is so
weak that we have the two main
complainants on record conspiring about
how to
how to lie and and entrap this guy but
he's still in jail to me it's it's
mind-bending it's it's Jewel when you
look at the the way that the Matrix
Works they tend to you you find patterns
the way that they handle one thing it's
the way that they handle most things so
the same way that they're handling this
mishap they take one thing that he
probably had an exchange with with one
of his girls at the time and they use
that to represent his entirety they do
that with him as a whole as a person
they'll take a clip out of context where
he's talking about one thing and they
will only show that one individual clip
I get it that's how the internet works
that's how Tick Tock works that's how
YouTube shorts works but they don't
actually show the long form content and
I saw Street interviews where women were
asked publicly like do you watch Andrew
Tate they're like yes I hate them
they're like what do you watch they're
like oh he's always on my for you page
they're like have you watched any
long-form content no I haven't so how do
you know someone like that then there it
is and for those who want to see the
current Tate watch tight's Final message
on Rumble it's there that's that's the
level-headed
non-playing a character Tate and it's
very different to that guy you know
talking all a good game but to your
point the most clear-cut example of that
Selective Sound biting you know that
clip where he's banging out the machete
boom in her face shut up and they're
like look Tate's talking about putting a
machete in someone's face yeah the full
long form says he has machetes around
his house yeah he he grew up rough man
South Side Chicago Luton these are
dangerous places he grew up rough you
know he was a professional fighter
people were trying to hurt him he's had
80-something fights so as a result he's
very safety conscious and he has a lot
of weapons in his house it's not a crime
none of them are illegal the pistols
that are in his house were from his
licensed security team let's not forget
that you know he doesn't break any laws
when it comes to weapon ownership or
he'd be charged like that but what we
see there is Tate was saying all right
so I've got a lot of uh knives around my
house some people say what if a woman
busted you cheating and got a machete
and put it in your face he said I would
bang out the machete grab her up he's
saying how he would react if the woman
was attacking him with a machete but
they completely removed that context and
they make it look like he's coming at
some woman with a machete which he would
never do yeah it's such nasty games how
convenient it is and all these so-called
investigative you know independent
journalists all these people who've
formed all these opinions on Tate they
haven't even watched the full form
videos
yet that somehow you know they can go on
a Twitter space and speak with some
Authority about a man who they've never
met and never even researched thoroughly
yeah it's quite remarkable yeah I mean
they they always need some kind of enemy
they always need some kind of narrative
they always need some kind of drama
being stirred up to the public so that
you know the government can always be
seen in a nice light you know they're
they're protecting us they're they're
handling human trafficking they're you
know they're protecting the citizens
um and if you look at other people like
politicians and like Julian Assange and
these people who America hates they also
have allegations against them and it's
the same exact method people came out or
did multiple women came out and said he
did this and that to me and that's your
answer there I mean again if you want
and I believe this very strongly if you
want to be intimate with a woman I think
your responsibility if I talk about
Traditional Values is to take care of
her if you want to be intimate with
multiple women then I think you should
take care of those multiple women within
the framework of Islam make it Halal
look after the minkily look after their
their family as well if you want to be
that big boy and have a bunch of
different women then do it properly as
per Islam and be the patriarch who takes
care of multiple families otherwise
having sex with a bunch of women leaves
you liable as a man because these sorts
of things can happen and for the longest
of time I've always been of the opinion
that
as you get more and more famous you need
to be more and more careful with who you
let into your life man or woman and if
you're bringing in a lot of low
frequency people some of them are going
to think hang on a sec I can work in a
job I don't want for hours and make x
amount of money or I could make claim
why against individual you know Zed and
make x amount of money
again to all the young men out there
if you have the urge for multiple women
get your money right convert to Islam
and have multiple wives otherwise you're
putting yourself at risk and also you're
not helping Society how does casual sex
help Society whereas if a man has
multiple wives in Islam and takes care
of multiple families in a world where
it's where have all the good men gone if
you're one of those good men who's
taking care of multiple families that is
a positive value ad for society so I
disagree with all this pickup culture
stuff and all this you know hit it and
quit it that damages the woman that
doesn't help Society I don't necessarily
think it damages a man but it's
definitely a waste of a man's potential
so again if you want multiple women be
prepared to take care of multiple women
and doing it do it properly and
ethically and under Islam that's my view
on this thing this is where it comes
back to what you said that everybody
needs them but then look at this Society
nowadays would you say that we are where
we are because there's a lack of
discipline there's a lack of order in
today's society yeah definitely I see
you right 100 I think and I think it's
primarily men's fault I don't believe in
blaming women for the state of society
and or blaming women because
you know
there's a lot of men I I find are angry
women nowadays because you know they
they can't find a good woman in the same
way women are angry men they can't find
a good man
if you are a good man and you you put in
the effort to maintain your physicality
to to have good men around you to build
businesses to to get your money right
you'll be able to find good women and
you'll be able to work with that partner
to create a loving and mutually
beneficial relationship I think where
Society has gone wrong is men have
forgotten that if you want a good
Traditional Values woman you've got to
be a good Traditional Values man that
takes work I've been employed since I
was nine years old and I've worked I've
been 90 countries around the world I've
worked in you know all the modern day
war zones I put work into being the man
and it when you get to that point maybe
then you can consider having multiple
women and multiple families well I think
the issue is a lot of young men nowadays
are like no no I want multiple women
without looking after them and without
having to put in the work to be in a
position where I can't look after them
that to me is a very I'm very against
this this dating culture and this hookup
culture because I think it directly
impacts Society in in a negative way
that's what I'm saying that is it's the
lack of discipline that makes the
mentally voice you know and thirsty
thirsty boys chasing chasing hedonistic
pleasure but they don't want to take a
full responsibility for ownership and
then Islam like that's what is being
promoted full responsibility full
ownership like if you're going to have
multiple women you better be able to
take care of multiple women and I don't
know if it's a coincidence actually no
nothing is a coincidence yeah but it's
like if you look at this if you look at
the the people and I'm going to say
people I want to include women into this
as well but if you look at people who
come to Islam
is because at some point another they
began to enforce some form of discipline
or some form of order within their lives
and when this begins to happen you begin
to come closer and closer to the truth
like you said you you spent a long time
trying to get to the point where you
were actually a good man that could
actually get a good woman like Allah
says in the Quran
good men are for good women and good
women not for Good Men but bad news yeah
and the more I hear the more I'm like
yes yes
and the next part he says that bad men
offer bad women and bad women offer
badmin meaning you literally will end up
with who you are was it 1 400 years ago
words that are so relevant to today tell
me there isn't power there it's
incredible incredible I love it all from
a man that
couldn't even read it yeah isn't that
wild me and Donald were talking about
this last night before we went to sleep
it was like what do we say bro we said
that something along the lines of when
you have uh when you have uh Islam
versus non-muslim ideologies right we're
doing the same thing we we understand
the same reality but we don't cap we say
it as it is you know what I mean like a
lot of people they'll say oh in Islamic
marriages and traditional marriages it's
like why is it so transactional the
manager is providing protecting and the
women are just giving intimacy and
serving like what is that it's not so
black and white we're like it's not not
a relationship between men and women but
you guys aren't admitting it there's all
this Foolery there's all this cap that
it's different you know we're here for
one another but is that not reality look
at the divorce rates yeah you know I
think a woman truly happy with a man
wants to submit to him wants to serve
him wants to make it one of her biggest
life goals two obey him because she
understands it's obeying Allah yeah and
serving him and a man understands that
he needs to take care of those that are
under his responsibility you know what I
mean like when you look at Muslim
countries we stand for very similar
things that the West stands for not in
content but the way that we stand for
them a perfect example of this is
tolerance the West has intolerance right
just like we in Muslim countries we have
intolerance right we're both similar in
that the thing is we're intolerant to
different things they're intolerant but
this the fact still stands that we're
both intolerant but when you come to
Muslim countries we're not shy about
that we make it clear this is what we're
talking about in the west there's all
this alive all this deception that oh
we're actually very tolerant we're
inclusive we don't have lines that you
can cross but they do 100 the left is
riddled with hypocrisy that's the one
thing the left is consistent on how
hypocritical they are for example in
certain Nordic countries yes we want
lots of immigrants to come in from you
know Somali Afghanistan hey but we don't
want them in the schools with our
children you know in the rich areas that
they're going to Great measures to keep
keep keep it separate like it's the left
is so full of hypocrisy it's amazing and
that's what's running the world at the
moment in the west that's why the West
is lost and that's why we see I mean as
a security professional London used to
be the place you can't even wear a nice
watch now where's the place Dubai
someone with Sharia law like it's yeah I
completely resonate with what you're
saying and we can see it on a global
level
I mean even on the example of you know
traditional roles they're traditional
for a reason why a traditional is a good
thing you know why is it like this is
how societies ran things for like
thousands of years and all of a sudden
we want to come and re recreate the
wheel and change it up completely what
are you doing I mean look at the Quality
and I'm not I don't just mean in value I
mean the quality of life for these men
and women have you seen a woman with a
good genuine husband and good genuine
kids who are unhappy nope how many women
are there who have the you know the the
boss babe job and the only fans and and
they're alone and they're single and
they don't have any kids and they hit 30
are they happy bro the issue with
Reinventing the wheel is that it hasn't
been tested why because it's new we're
traditionally you know it stands because
that's what God is here in the first
place it's a very modern societal
construct and also one thing I like
about Islam is I think it resonates very
closely with Biology if we break humans
down and again this is very you know
simplified men our key driver is
testosterone the urge in testosterone is
to fornicate and to for combat you know
for violence yeah
we should have men
exercising that in a healthy way such in
healthy marriages you know as the
patriarch but also things like fight
sports like boxing like there are ways
to express that that ER that men have in
a healthy manner then on the female side
we have estrogen
and oxytocin from what I understand and
and that's the urge to to build a
relationship a home to be settled to to
be essentially taken care of
why would you not try and live in line
with these biological urges with with
the chemicals in our blood why would you
not try and
you know men who were driven by
testosterone to be big muscular strong
discipline providing protecting women
who estrogen to be
you know building that found a unit
having that that safety around them like
why are we going against biology until
your point it's a very modern societal
experiment and it's not working again
the more liberal a country is the higher
the divorce rates the higher the issues
with single-parent families and
everything is documented the higher
antidepressant use this this modern day
societal experiment is not working yeah
we have to keep pretending that it is it
keeps getting pushed down our throats I
have young children I don't like them
watching Netflix anymore because the
agenda is pushed so strongly and also
I'll be completely blunt I I worked with
numerous when I was a soldier I had
numerous friends who were gay as
soldiers nothing but respect for them
these guys were killers they were
serious operators serious guys you
wouldn't know their sexual preference
just like you wouldn't know anyone
else's
and to me again maybe that's against
Islam but I don't mind that
for me someone if someone wants to do
whatever they want to do in the house
who am I to judge it's their life what I
draw issue with is why are we pushing
these agendas on children and we see
watch Netflix watch your kids program on
Netflix you will see
things of a sexual nature being pushed
on children to me that is that is just
evil why would you do that why would you
push whether it's straight gay this that
the other why would you push anything
sexual on young children's Minds that's
what I really really view with shaytan
and I like that Islam says no to that
sort of thing and to me it ties into me
saying that Islam is the only solution
to this liberalism that's ruining
Western Society I'm going to the Irani
brother because you know that in Islam
we can't Chuck what happens behind
people's doors bro spying is Haram right
if if two people doing whatever behind
closed doors what's the Islamic
understanding of that yeah 100 so in
Sharia Allah whenever there's some kind
of fornication but whether it's
same-sexer or opposite sex when it's
outside of marriage you need four male
Witnesses who and this is the main key
it's not just any Witnesses like oh a
random woman testified against Andrew
Tate it's people who are known in the
community who people can also basically
testify for them that they're good and
trusted people yeah exactly and so you
need four of these men if you can prove
that one of these men like doesn't even
pray or something then like they're
wiped out as well they don't come so we
need four of these people to testify the
same exact story and they saw the pen go
in the ink right interesting and on at
the same time it's Haram to spy on
people so if something happens behind
closed doors we're not allowed to go spy
and prion people trying to catch him in
the action
um and you need four people to see the
same exact thing for them to be
convicted of anything so it's this huge
deterrent you know to commit fornication
but at the same time if it does happen
you know me and on hill and fired being
there's not enough you know another way
to look at what Ram is saying is it's a
deterrent because you need four male
Witnesses you have to see the pen go in
the ink then how is that even gonna
happen unless most likely they're not
under closed doors or behind closed
doors yeah they're most likely outside
they're most likely where they shouldn't
be and that's the whole thing with the
Qatar in the World Cup like we don't
have an issue with what you guys want to
do and how you want to practice your
life but don't come into our country
bring in your rainbow flag and put that
in our faces because again at the end of
the day it's a sexual symbol at that
point why is something sexual being
displayed out where kids can see it like
in places like uh in the nordics they
have these Pride parades again
do what you want in your life why are
you doing in public with kids involved
you'll see kids walking in a private
parade waving a flag why it's a sexual
thing we wouldn't expose them to again
this drag time like Story Hour yeah
we're not going to bring in female
strippers dressed like strippers nope
but if we bring in a transsexual that's
all right in front of kids to me it's
it's broken and I can't fathom how it's
it's beneficial and how it's permitted
and that's why I will never like accept
that the West is not broken I think it's
a failed Society
this is where we have to look at the
bigger picture and we have to look at
what Andrew Tay has been doing he's been
trying to make men wake up and be strong
men be actual masculine men
and in society like if we actually look
at the bigger picture what I don't want
to say people in control because who am
I to know exactly who is in control but
we'll say the elite at the top
these people
if they have a certain agenda which we
have no idea about we're not claiming
anything
if there's people like this if they have
an agenda like you said anyone may they
want men to be soft they wouldn't want
men to band together and be stronger why
would they want this that's dangerous
the fighting age males banded together
you know focused on a certain cause
that's dangerous yeah yeah and look if
you have men that are older now and
they've woken up and they're actually
going towards that you can't really
impact them but the kids oh yeah wow
there it is oh that's why it's happening
man
true I I can sit and watch Netflix that
won't change how I think exactly but you
put an eight-year-old in front of that
and there's not just the kids now let's
add another layer on to this tell me
that's not shaytan Habibi bro not just
the kids
but are women remember we were talking
about this if you if the woman is toxic
in the household the entire household is
affected so if a woman is impacted by
these different ideologies and these
there's different ways she's being
programmed to snake Whispering the snake
whispering to Eve yes so if he's
thinking this way well not the whole
household is singing this way and if
she's raising the kids like you said now
you have the the mother teaching the kid
this this wrong way and then he's going
to school or she's going to school and
they're being taught this wrong way as
well you have kids in like fifth grade
sixth grade seventh grade and they're
being taught this curriculum
the lgbtq whatever okay we can block
that out listen they're being taught
this as a curriculum like science and
history
it reminds me of what you were saying
that this is what makes men happy in
life and this is what makes tend to make
women happy I like to use the word
fulfilled for me happiness comes and
goes deep and fulfillment is what we're
chasing right and we live authentically
true to ourselves there it is but what's
crazy is that's what Allah already told
us that in Islam we understand that a
man's responsibility is Authority and
maintaining his family and for a woman
it's their home there it is there it is
and and again that ties into the fact
that to me Islam is so close to biology
how can you even argue against it you
guys have done that little rabbit hole
where we we use the this symbology of
the snake whispering to Eve about you
know go and eat that apple and then
nowadays what we have is social media
and it's really spiking the levels of
narcissism and things especially in
women and of course
the phones that we access the social
media from have an apple on the back you
guys have done that right so the way it
correlates with that old Adam and Eve
and the Apple story it's pretty crazy
when you look at it like that and who I
mean just to follow the analogy who was
the snake in that story
time
I mean people are going to be like oh
they're conspiracy theorists and that
stuff but if you're a Muslim and you're
religious or even if you're a Christian
you're and you believe in God you
believe in the devil you know that the
shaytan especially as a Muslim we know
he's existed for a very very long time
before human beings were even created he
was actually up with the angels because
he was such a good worshiper of Allah
you know and this is a good you know
side note for a lot of people out there
and narcissism and all that stuff
ibiza's fault was not because he said I
don't believe in God anymore you know
that's stupid he spoke to Allah he spoke
to God his fault was when Allah
commanded him to prostrate towards Adam
out of respect of a new creation for God
and he said no I'm not doing that no I'm
better than him I'm better you made me
from a smokeless fire he's made from
dirt you want me to you know to to do
saju to put my head in the ground
towards this guy I don't care if he made
him you know and that's what got him
banished and that's he was so angry you
know Adam he's like I'm going to bring
as many people down to Hell Fire as I
can that was his mission and and when
you look at how he first started he went
right to the attendance of Adam as soon
as Adam died at least and the good and
the this like the scholars the upright
men died he went to the Next Generation
he was like these were good people you
know you should have some way to honor
them later he brought he basically got
them to build statues of these people
later he got stories that these people
were amazing they did this and that and
then later started worshiping the idols
they started worshiping the statues
interesting works on steps yeah he's not
going to come to you right away and tell
you what he wants you to do and He will
utilize he will utilize even the
religion you know he'll have people be
so extreme of the religion that they
take themselves out of the fall of Islam
just with their extremism their crazy
beliefs that aren't Islamic at all he'll
use the phones he'll use the media he
use all these Avenues possible and he'll
use the people as well you know Allah
says in the Quran
from the Jinn and from mankind there are
human human like Devils out there
basically interesting and what I love
about this is it's such a powerful
archetype that every old book talks
about the concept of shaytan you know
the Temptation always always whispering
even if we go to the paganistic
religions they also have these devil
Figures it's so ancient and so
archetypal when there's so much power in
understanding these things and how it
relates to modern day life atheists are
missing a whole level of understanding
they're just missing out on that that
way to perceive The Human Experience I
really believe that but it's ironic they
claim that we're missing out on Leaf
we're missing out on the fruits of the
Dunya
that's what happens when you limit
yourself you know they limit themselves
to the physical world things that they
can test and all that stuff so if there
is and this is hypothetical for them but
it's still real enough for them to have
to consider if there is a whole other
world of the spiritual realm realm that
you cannot test or see empirically with
you know these Tech these devices in a
microscope and that stuff then you're
missing out on a whole aspect of life
but they don't care about that because
they genuinely believe and this is a
byproduct of like secularism they
genuinely believe there's nothing beyond
the physical world which they themselves
when they fall asleep and have a dream
and empty all this stuff
not only is it a useless belief in life
and and being pragmatic and benefiting
people and yourselves but it's something
that's completely unprecedented you know
with the whole discussion of does
Consciousness exist in the mind is it
all physical and when they go to sleep
and but they have dreams and all that
stuff these are evidences against what
they believe and even you know the
belief in a God is something that is so
fundamental that they didn't they did a
an experiment at Oxford University City
where they went got a lot of different
children different backgrounds different
beliefs beliefs different upbringings
they ask them all do you believe in God
or higher power every single one of them
said yes every single one of them isn't
that interesting yeah I like it this
brings me to my next question that what
are your personal goals if you want to
share them as a Muslim know okay first
and foremost is the Arabic language I
need to get that back up to speed and
even better than it was because for me
for me to get on a purely selfish level
but then it you know there are positive
ramifications for those who I interact
with
if prayer is action and you are
effectively self-programming yourself
with positive words
you need to not only say the words
you've got to understand them and so I
want to not just be able to pray in you
know with detail or read the Quran you
know with slowly I'm sure but with some
level of proficiency I wonder because I
can I can say the words now I want to
understand them so it's that
understanding which is my main focus in
terms of my practice but in terms of
sort of on a more holistic level
I want to continue the trend where Islam
is making me even more motivated to get
the most out of every day to learn the
most that I can to to you know pray as
as we are meant to and I really want to
find ways to
especially with Andrew to to
give what we can in terms of whether
it's attention or or money I mean
alhamdulillah you know I'm I'm finding
life money-wise I'd like some really
purposeful zakat not just oh yeah I sent
ten thousand dollars to wherever I want
us to build something that is real
and and has a positive impact on the
world and Andrew has talked about this
as well even before Islam that he wanted
to I mean he has had various charitable
initiatives but we want to do something
special something big and that so that's
that's that'll be a real focus when
Andrew's out I'm very sure when he comes
out you'll see the the current Andrew
which is someone who's aware of the fact
that they have a huge amount of
influence and a platform for putting on
a very positive message in the world a
big part of that will be will be charity
will be philanthropy so that's that's
the end State um
on a side note how is all that looking
uh the case and everything yeah how is
that looking okay so from what I
understand from talking to people who
are you know right in the middle of it
everyone who looks at the Case Files is
a maze that they're even detained in the
first place that's the cons from the
professionals you know I don't claim to
be a lawyer I'm you know I'm not reading
on the case everyone who looks at the
real details and has access to the Case
Files goes what really that's it so at
the end of the day Romania is still an
EU country they're still
you know there is Justice there
the take Brothers will get out because
unless there's some amazing new find
which there won't be because I know who
these guys are and who they aren't and
also it's been ongoing for how many
months
there will be a trial hopefully sooner
rather than later let's stop dragging it
out and they will win that that is
inshallah that is the end State and so
the question is how long will they be
held before that trial starts and let I
mean for me it's like let's do it let's
do this trial because then they can beat
it but they can't beat this gray area
where there's no real charges and all
these sorts of things but yeah again my
key message would be every single
professional who's been reading on the
case has been amazed at how weak the
evidence is and and from what I
understand the response has been really
they're detained over this like it's
that that week it's almost like they
have them in prison and now they're
looking for evidence 100 that's exactly
what it is 100 what it is and and for me
again this is just part of the Tates
Story the Redemption Arc is is going to
be glorious I think you know being
around Tate they thought the Redemption
Arc would be all right we're canceled
off social media we're going to come
back with an even bigger Fame as a
result an even more positivity to to
positively motivate you know the the
mostly the men of the world but now this
is the Redemption Arc coming back from
this and being even more famous and even
more positively impactful that's that's
the end state of this and also I know a
lot of people are concerned about the
Tates they're okay man they're combat
ready those guys are they're serious
guys in terms of their situational
awareness in terms of their mental
fortitude in terms of their discipline
again as Allah says
the the you know he won't give you that
which you can't deal with the tits can
deal with a lot and trust me they can
deal with a lot this I put it I put it
to you know everybody what the Tates are
going through here this isn't the most
difficult thing they've dealt with no
way no way and they know who they are
they know what they have and haven't
done they know they're going to win so
now it's just patience and that that's
challenging though like Andrew
especially he's not a patient guy he
doesn't like sitting around doing
nothing so let's hope that his time is
spent you know studying the Quran who's
tweeting the tweets from his account I
was gonna ask him yeah yeah from what I
understand there's a direct line of
communication from Andrew uh through a
lawyer to whoever has control of that so
it is Andrew from from what I understand
he is as I understand it he's
communicating every day to his team yeah
have you been able to speak there no I
haven't I have I I'd at the end of the
day I think his
his main focus is is that you know the
legal Challenge and all these sorts of
things so I I heard a conversation here
was on where I said to him hey brother
just let you know I'm praying in the in
the Masjid for you every day he said
thank you but beyond that we haven't
talked no
but he's good man like he's that that is
a disciplined strong-minded dude I
wouldn't worry about him and he's going
to come out stronger than ever more
focused than ever more aware of his duty
to bring a positive message to the Youth
of today's world well I mean who else is
speaking about you know in in a
masculine way in a motivational way to
the Youth of today is there anyone else
really that can compete with Tate and
his powerful message despite what the
media says with all this negative press
the positive messages that he puts out
which is 90 plus percent of his content
who else really is is putting out a
message that resonates so powerfully
with the youth so he will come out he'll
continue if anything he all of that old
Tate will be gone forever it was already
gone this is what people don't realize
what they're bringing up is old content
so you're going to see a lot more
focused I believe a lot more in touch
with his faith a lot more
really driven to to make the most of
this influence he has money uh you know
there's I don't think money will drive
him anymore I think it'll be how can I
leave a positive Legacy on the world so
if anything the powers that be are just
creating an even more
focused Andrew who's going to be even
more clear on his positive messaging to
the Youth of the world I think at the
end of the day it's all positive he is
going to come out a lot more impactful
and a lot more focused on his duty to
use the influence he has to bring a
positive impact on society look at this
product we've got this part out but
initially we planned to come here and do
a podcast with Andrew Tate and
alhamdulillah now didn't work out yet
will we inshallah until he's out but we
spend the whole day with shooter and you
know we went to the Masjid and it
doesn't warm your heart bro as soon as
we walk in there we see all these
brothers then some of them are coming
from construction some of them coming
from this field that field but you go to
any of them and you offer them all the
money in the world to denounce their
faith they're not going to do it I
wouldn't that's that's that's discipline
and that's what's lacking in Western
Society right there it's again I would
love I mean look I don't consider myself
to be a debater but I would love anyone
to try and debate the fact that Islam is
not the only solution against shaytan
and against the the decaying Western
society that we see please somebody if
you're out there I would love to have
that conversation because I don't see
any argument against Islam fixing the
the the downfall of society due to
Western modernity and liberalism and
progressivism you want to know what to
do here liberal women say though that of
course he's Muslim of course the
religion that we can convert to is Islam
of course the thing they pick that he
picks to become is a Muslim because he
knows that you know
you know he's like he's going to pick
the one thing that you know oppresses
women the most that's misogynistic the
most what would you say to that
I I think that's
that just don't understand Islam or what
I think that's cope I think westerners
or liberals who say oh Islam is
misogynistic that's cope for their lack
of one their understanding but two if I
was a liberal and I saw traditional
families Guided by
you know God
fulfilled people I'd be pretty angry
inside I would see my religion that of
the religion of wokism in their heart
they know they're not happy then if they
look and see these these beautiful
families and these brothers who are
bonded together and these women who are
fulfilled being women and men who are in
you know fulfilled being men
if I was a liberal I'd be pretty angry
at that because that confronts me with
the fact that my religion isn't working
for me so I think it's all just cope I
really do and the idea that somehow
Traditional Values are misogynistic
I know a lot of women who are in
traditional relationships who laugh and
say hang on a second I'm provided for
I'm protected my emotional needs are met
in that my man listens to me and cares
for me if I want to have kids I don't
have to maintain a corporate career and
I can stop and have kids this this where
all the good man gone I've got one of
these good men
okay oppressed me some more then what's
the problem if that's if that's
oppression they're happy they'd like
more oppression like it's I think it's
all just cope and
to all the Liberals out there these
these liberal Western women
I think there'd be I know there'd be a
lot more fulfilled if they found
themselves a traditional Dynamic where
that wherever all the good men gone type
man was there looking after them I mean
women can make their own money when we
can have their own jobs they can do it
if they want but if you have a masculine
man next to you who listens to you
supports you protects you provides for
you on every level not just the physical
tell me that isn't what the liberal
feminists want a a partner in life who's
truly supportive take away the gender
thing if you've got someone else living
in your house wouldn't you want that
person to feel it's my duty to really
look after you yeah but whereas if
you're in some you know feminist type
Society where the man is
you know weak and undisciplined he can't
take care of himself let alone take care
of a woman tell me all of these these
people who are hating on Traditional
Values and saying oh it's misogynistic
tell me they themselves don't want a
strong caring
successful
traditional man of course they do
everyone wants a partner who can look
after them properly so I just I just any
any negativity and this is why I'm okay
being off Twitter all these leftists
getting angry and and throwing hate
around how are your belief systems
working out for you friend how is your
religion of wokism making your heart
full and and making you sleep well at
night
just have a look at yourself before you
throw negativity of people who are
actually fulfilled in their lives who
have a belief system that's actually
working for them but most people don't
want to confront this and look in the
mirror see their own face see when you
look at when you look at a lot of these
women one can argue that sure they're
victims we're all victims to some extent
right but they've never met that guy
that guy that can take care of them be
that guy for them you know and sure yeah
sorry about that oh God what do they
fantasize about
that I actually saw a study and again
it's a Haram to talk about it there's a
direct correlation between being a
feminist and consuming hardcore
pornography exactly there are studies
out there wow you can look this up from
a reputable like peer-reviewed studies
literature when we look at 50 Shades of
Gray what were the countries where it
was selling I don't think the worst
women in fulfilled relationships need to
read about getting tied up and whipped
I'm just going to put that out there
it's so the more I believe it might be
in a you know a simplification the more
a woman is I Don't Need No Man how dare
you be you know traditional and
misogynistic the more she's driven to
that hardcore a rough strong man being
rough with me there's direct correlation
there so you can you can deny it with
your mind but we still have very old
through the generations programming
Primal needs exactly sorry to cut you
off there but no noise but when you look
at this like we're all victims to some
extent so that woman hasn't met that guy
but she's still reading books
fantasizing about thinking about that
guy about that guy right and the reality
is sure you you give her that guy maybe
she'll change your way but there comes
to a point where we need to take
personal accountability as men and women
we can no longer just push the needle of
victimization forward and be like you
know what I've been through this my dad
wasn't there this is my life I don't
trust no man and this is what I'm going
to continue that's why they get so
triggered at Tate and Tristan and and
all these people telling him as it is
because it forces them to kind of take
accountability realize you know what the
way that I think the world has figured
out it's wrong it's not actually change
everything my belief system is not
working but there's so much so much
easier to just be like you know what no
they're misogynist they're backwards I'm
good with my life I'm gonna chase my
career yeah I refer to it as The
Sisterhood of victimhood that's how I
view feminism and I have a daughter I
don't talk about our opening but I have
a young daughter from an early age
martial arts she she the first time I
have videos of her when she could just
walk I was holding her hand and she was
kicking a pad being held by the trainer
because I'm not going to raise a woman
who's a victim I'm going to raise a
woman who is strong who is capable and
also another thing when my daughter was
young
never ever was anyone allowed to come
and hug her or grab her without her
permission even me if I came to hug her
and she didn't feel like it okay I'll
respect your space I taught her from a
very early age you're not a victim you
have the right to say no this is my wall
or no often she's shy with new people
and people like oh hey I'm like don't
touch her she doesn't want to talk to
you you don't touch her she she's I'm
not raising her to be a victim I'm
raising her to know this is my line this
is what I'm comfortable with I'm fully
empowered to say no to have my personal
space why would you raise women to be
victims
per the feminist view when you could
raise them to be empowered confident to
have some physicality to know where the
line is and to be empowered to say no
I'm not comfortable with this and to
make noise and change the situation I
think raising women to feel that their
victims is very damaging also from a
personal security level again I'm a
security professional I have been for a
long time if you want takeaway gender
someone to be a sovereign individual who
is safe in the world you don't want them
walking around feeling like they're a
victim or under threat you want them
putting time into training you want them
having that no stop I'm not comfortable
with this why aren't we teaching women
that if we really care about women why
are we telling them that there are
victims I don't I don't gel with that
sort of thinking at all before we'll get
back in the podcast we've got a very
special announcement as you can see we
are here in Masjid
father Muslim Brothers out there that
are trying to level up that game we have
our first drop coming out soon we have
200 pieces that are going to be released
within the straw so that's something
you're trying to do then click the link
on the screen in the description box
down below to get 10 off on the drop day
which is March 31st and make sure to
check your email box so you can see if
you got the message check your spam
folder as well to see if you got the
message like where you can be on point
and be notified as soon as we release
this clothing on my study first five
percent of all proceeds are going to
building Masjid in Norway so make sure
that you are checking your email so that
you can confirm and be notified when we
drop on March 31st collection is going
to be called Victory impatience in honor
of Andrew and Tristan Tate for what
they're going through right now so let's
make Dua so that Allah releases them as
soon as possible and brings them out in
the best state that he can possibly
bring them out in and with that being
said let's get right back into the
podcast
foreign
yeah so what I want to say on this man
is it goes back to the bigger picture
there's something else going on because
they're also trying to control the woman
but you know the men but they're trying
to control the women and if you look at
it like we have this thing that's really
big it's really popping now and it's
social media all right you got Tick Tock
you got Instagram you got YouTube you
got even more than this like it's not
what it used to be now they've designed
it to where it keeps you in there the
dopamine addiction's real man yeah and
when it keeps you in there you become
more Mindless and scroll more and more
and more and you it puts you in this
submissive state to what you're looking
assuming instead of producing and
imagine you have all these uh subliminal
messages that are popping up on there
but you're such in a Mindless state that
you're not catching in on it think about
this women are the ones that are tend to
be on social media the most that's true
yeah men we do tend to be on social
media uh but for the most part for men
it's been the pornography yeah okay you
know and isn't it wild the way the left
pushes pornography I saw at one point
this no nut November concept where men
don't masturbate yeah the left went wild
saying it's bad and dangerous the left
wants you to consume pornography and to
be weak and like it's it's wild man it's
so blatant it's so
clearly before we before we go on with
the rest of our questions do you have
any questions for us or anything that
you've had on your mind you wanted to I
mean to be honest I feel like I know you
guys pretty well because I've watched a
fair video stuff
it's my honor to host you guys in my
house it really is a real honor and also
I want to say guys why are you living in
a failed Society
soon and well I I'll do everything I can
to help you guys set up here I really I
see what you're doing is very valid and
I'd love to support it if you guys as a
podcast were a a company listed on a
stock exchange I would invest in you wow
well it's true though you're going to
continue to grow you guys are doing this
for the right reasons even when we we
said daughter before we started that
touched me you guys are not doing this
for clout or for or more followers look
at me you were genuinely putting forward
a very positive message which has for
the Youth of today like it's needed it
really is so anything I can do to
support I'd love to but I really think
guys with respect you talk about you
know the importance of of living true to
your beliefs why are you in the West
yeah it's so weird that that you
reverted to Islam and moved here yeah
bro we've had Islam for so long and
we're still living in the garden as well
one thing I can say for sure is that we
have been talking about it a lot
actually we have it's in the works
already excellent excellent excellent
well yeah I know a few people here I
believe I could add some value so
however I can help let me help you guys
get set up have you may Allah reward you
may Allah
it's on camera
but that does bring the question now
after you moved over here to the Middle
East what have you noticed specifically
on a societal level compared to the West
I mean there's different types of the
Middle East right and I've lived in all
of them I've lived in Levant I've spent
a lot of time in in North Africa
um a lot of time in the Gulf as well to
me to try and put the Middle East is one
doesn't really work I view them as
different places
um
as far as societal changes with the West
I don't even view the West as as a place
that's functioning properly so for me to
to compare the two it's like comparing
oranges and apples you know what I mean
so I'm not sure if I can really answer
that question I um
I I'm very grateful for for Dubai I'm
very grateful for countries that uh
that have leadership that are Guided by
faith I used to think back in the day
you know I was in no way a Marxist or
anything heaven forbid but I used to
think the idea of mixing State and
religion was a bad thing but then I
realized hang on a second
you want politicians without any sort of
accountability to God running the people
what are they going to do they can look
after themselves right they can do even
if it costs you know the people they're
going to do what looks after themselves
to me now the most
well that the best countries on Earth in
terms of leadership are from leaders who
feel accountable to God and I think the
the UAE is a fantastic example of that
this is
technically I believe uh you could call
it a dictatorship right a patriarchal
I'm not I'm not sure the exact title but
I feel a lot more free here than I would
in the west I can say what I want to say
as long as you don't respect the leaders
of course I mean they're built this why
would you disrespect them right
incredible achievement as long as you
don't respect disrespect Islam and again
why would you do that if you follow the
rules here you are more free in this
so-called you know dictatorship then
you'd be in the west any day and again
if we want to talk about Freedom these
watches man we'll get we'll get a hammer
in the head in London for that how is
that freedom yeah in in many places in
the west if you disagree with what your
kids are being taught at school in terms
of the agenda being pushed on them you
are the bad guy and the government can
look into you there are certain
countries and certain examples where
fathers have been against their sons
be going on puberty blockers and the
state has come in and said no how dare
you do that yeah how is that freedom
yeah whereas here you wouldn't you
wouldn't confront you wouldn't be
confronted with that sort of stuff yeah
it's yeah I mean that issue of puberty
blockers wouldn't be an issue to begin
with you know over there there are
actually been some men who have been
penalized or fined or thrown in jail for
a contesting you know to to surgery to
you know their own children yeah how is
that freedom it's it's an Obama the same
thing with women bro like in Western
women they claim they're liberal they're
they're liberated not liberal they're
free they're finally powerful and
empowered right how's that working out
for you that's the question I'd ask to
all these liberals how's that working
out for you to the vice guys when we did
this Vice documentary because I spent a
lot of time with them it was my job to
make sure that the warm guys would
actually talk to them because all these
warm guys are like we don't trust when
they came and live with their teeth uh
no yeah when they were at this event
okay and okay these Vice guys especially
the main guy he's not a happy dude
he's not a fulfilled guy he at certain
points when he was around the
Brotherhood and he was being pushed and
encouraged to train and fight and be
masculine you could see he was really
about it and he actually said off camera
I see what you guys are doing here I see
that it's valuable wow he was starting
to feel the energy of having Brothers in
a supportive Community around you but of
course now Tate's bad and he's back to
his liberal existence where they're
pushing different agendas where Vice is
pushing drug use I I put it to anybody
if you want to see the worth of
someone's belief system just ask how is
that working out for him how is that
working out for you all these leftists
to me they do not look like happy
fulfilled people they do not look like
they have strong supportive Brothers
around them like they have strong loyal
caring women around them it's again how
is your belief system working out for
you is the question I would love to have
with any of these Vice reporters or any
of these people who are coming after
Tate how is your world view working out
for your friend yeah you know show us
some show us some receipts show us some
receipts you see women here in the club
walking around and it's such a direct
diametrically opposed worldview that we
as Muslim men have we have protective
jealousy over our women right we're now
here sharing our wives and and they
don't need to be out there having you
know social media and all this type of
stuff but they'll call us oppressive
because of that they'll say you're
controlling you're insecure when to me I
think that that's what western men do
they're insecure about speaking up
voicing how they feel the way that Allah
has designed us with these
characteristics that are fitra and
they'll use shaming tactics you know
like toxic masculinity all this to just
neuter you as a man and also this does
bring me to the fact of polygeny too
because it's an innate predisposition in
men right not all men have it to the
same extent and I also don't want you
talking about your personal life but are
you a proponent of the idea of polygyny
obviously islamically we know it's
permissible but just you do you like the
idea of polygyny do you support that or
do you think that it's something that we
need to be careful about so I'd answer
that by saying show me a married man who
is faithful to his woman and doesn't use
pornography by himself in the bathroom
on his iPad
uh
uh are you saying this for every man are
you saying for like Muslim men as well
no no I'm saying in okay let's let's
clarify in the west show me a man who is
married to a woman and first of all I
like that line I think it was a comedian
who said it men are as faithful as their
options all these men in the west who
have money they all have Mistresses they
all see prostitutes because they have
options they have a work wife so then
you have yeah then you have a
demographic of men who don't have the
financial means to go and have sex with
multiple women so what do they do they
take their iPad into the bathroom at
night and they consume pornography again
show me a man who really doesn't have
any urge for multiple women or a variety
of some sorts actually you're going to
have to check his testosterone levels
there's going to be something wrong I'm
like I'm not trying to be humorous any
any healthy testosterone level man is
going to have an urge for multiple women
you can express that urge in a healthy
way right in the Islamic context where
you were taking care of the women who
you were intimate with because again I'm
strongly against this idea of hit it and
quit it if you have sex with a woman and
then you essentially you know then kick
her out of your life you've you've
degraded her I believe it's not healthy
for her I don't think men having sex
with lots of women impacts them in that
way but I personally believe that if a
woman has sex with a lot of men I think
it's quite it leads to unhappiness in
them I really believe that now you can
argue against that if you want but
that's that's my Human Experience that's
what I've seen so my answer is 100 and
another reason why I respect Islam is it
aligns with Biology we know that men
have these urges another example is golf
I played a lot of golf and golf is not
so much about what golf is it's about
what golf isn't golf is a space where
there aren't women around
and so what do men do they complain
about the fact that their sex life with
their wives is not very interesting and
they talk about their latest mistress or
they talk about the latest you know
prostitute their frequenting if you if
you really want to see whether
men are happy with
one woman
go and play golf with some guys and hear
the stories and again how many men who
are with one woman and have you know
don't have an issue with their
testosterone level don't consume
pornography why are they consuming
pornography because again they have that
urge for multiple women so again I think
Islam is very healthy in that all right
so you have an urge for multiple women
put the effort in to be the sort of man
who can take care of modern women and
multiple families I believe if you're
gonna if you really want to be a
traditional man and you're going to have
multiple women it's your duty to protect
to look after her parents to provide for
her parents her parents and I don't know
whether that's an Islamic thing or not
but if a woman you love
was raised by the parents and she is now
coming into the traditional role where
she won't be working she'll just be
serving you then guess what I think it's
your duty to look after her parents
within reason of course so if you really
if you have that urge for multiple women
why not Channel it into becoming so
successful that you can then care for
multiple families hence doing it in a
safe way there's no disease risk there's
no it's not just disease when you have
sex with women who you don't really care
for it's it's unhealthy energetically I
swear it's not a healthy thing for your
soul or your heart or however you want
to conceptualize that so use that urge
for multiple women to become a man who
has the means to look after multiple
families it's healthy for you it's
healthy for the woman it's healthy for
society because as we know where have
all the good men gone
so I think it's a very positive thing
but I think again it's up to men to take
that self-accountability to say all
right if I've got a really strong urge
for model women I need to work
I need to make that money I need to be
that man who is able to not just
financially care for but emotionally
care for multiple families to guide to
lead you want to be the patriarch it's a
lot of effort so what I love about Islam
is to say all right you have that urge
you want to sleep with multiple women
guess what you're going to have to take
care of them and guess what you have to
do equally and it's going to take real
work I think it's ideal and I think if
we look at it in terms of a way to run
society and to take men's urge for
sexual variety
and and expressed in a positive way that
we're using that urge to create a more
positive Society tell me it's not a good
thing if you have men who are taking
care of multiple Families how is that
bad for society so I'm I'm strongly for
it but again it's up to the man to build
himself into a man who's able to do that
so we've been a brother my brother so
unfortunately Rami has uh after the
intermission Rami was taking human
growth hormone and now this is the new
and improved Army uh for the next bit
insha Allah bro how you doing
so we want to introduce I am the Warner
who is a YouTuber uh by the name of
wahhab may Allah bless you bro you've
been on YouTube for not even a hot
minute bro it hasn't been that long and
immense success he's doing a little bit
of a kind of what we're doing with that
one but he does a little bit of a street
dollar do you want to talk about your
channel a little bit first and foremost
I just want to say I appreciate you guys
you know um it's been a great pleasure
and a great honor knowing you guys and
it's been a great honor you know being a
guest in your house as well and being in
your guys's presence as well it's a
great great blessing all praise is the
most high and uh regarding the channel
yes uh you know
my channel I'm actually very very proud
of what it is I'm doing and Tate was
actually a big inspiration you know of
really me starting what I'm doing and
before teaching people yeah you know
yeah before he was actually even Muslim
you know he was talking about something
uh one time I was just watching him and
he was talking about you know that
nowadays we live and you know there is a
pandemic going on but it's not the
pandemic that we think it is it's a
pandemic of cowards men have become weak
right and because of that it's
destroying what's going on is destroying
the whole system right and
once I realized that I had to ask myself
a question as well am I one of those
weak men am I one of those cowards are
you speaking about so I have to be
honest I have to be aware with myself
and I decided you know what I'm going to
stand up for the truth no matter what it
takes and obviously we live in society
now that's full of lies so if we speak
the truth in a society full of lies
there is going to be repercussions but
obviously there's going to be great
rewards as well you know so right now
what I'm doing is I'm just trying to
make history man I'm trying to make
history and I want to make a change in
the world extremely positive change the
world and I want to do something that's
outside of me I want to do something
that's not something selfish just for
myself and for my family but something
that I could give to the world and also
to benefit not just me but all the Sons
and Daughters of Adam I think it's very
very important that we all know we are
all connected we're all one we're one
body we all come we all have the same
father and we have the same mother which
is Adam and Eve so once the sooner we
realize that the sooner the world will
come United as one and I want to be part
of that inshallah bless you for that I
mean so I actually have a message for my
brother Tate
I know you don't know me but I know you
and I want to let you know you made such
a dramatic impact on my life in such a
positive way no matter what happens to
you I want to let you know that you have
changed the world you have truly changed
the world and you've changed my life and
I am so grateful for you I am so
grateful for you and because you changed
my life now I'm gonna pass that forward
and I'm going to change the lives of
others as well in extremely positive way
and inshallah we will see the fruits of
this labor that Tate has been portraying
to the world and he's activating other
people to do this as well so may Allah
bless Tate and bless him for eternity
inshallah I just want to say brother
when is that we're gonna do this again
inshallah inshallah but definitely but
inshallah definitely
new merch coming out soon
all right grateful to have you here
brother really really genuinely
okay my brothers so
Bismillah continuing so the big fella
went on a calorie restriction diet
the toilet break was rather excessive
I'm sorry but like the people that that
just saw Bob they're probably like where
did Will Hop come guys he's Mr Producer
he's been here all along baby you just
have no idea he's been here take it away
on her okay okay so
uh beautiful response to what you said
about the polygeny and all that stuff
and I do believe it's it's also very
needed in today's day and age now the
point that I want to make is a different
Viewpoint is uh not going for either or
but understanding that everything that
we do as men we need we have a very high
level of accountability and
responsibility yeah and we need to take
full ownership for that so if a man
decides
I want my Khadijah
and that was the the first wife of the
Prophet Muhammad
he did not have any other wives when he
was with her so if a man decides I want
my khalida okay number one this one damn
well better be that Khadija and he
better be putting in the work he better
not be using that as an excuse just to
be weak you know and then two if a man
wants to be having multiple women if he
wants to have his Aisha
then he needs to also be ready to take
on the work necessary to provide not
only for her but
the family like you said and the
multiple other women and their family so
I think that's like the most important
Viewpoint that I kind of want to bring
you and I want to you know hear your
thoughts on it now because you you were
talking about polygiene and I know like
it's very valid it's very um on point
I'm not negating it but now with like
bringing in this new thing where it's
like you know either or can be fine as
long as the men are taking full
responsibility full ownership and uh
they understand that if they choose one
woman they're still going to have that
desire within them but they can still uh
direct it and channel it in different
healthy way in a productive way yeah so
so I I think
the the first thing that I think I want
to acknowledge is since when is the West
the authority on on morals on how to
live the you know
the idea that polygyny to be honest I'm
not even familiar with that word
in many different cultures and indeed
throughout history
men who are the Patriarchs or the tribal
leaders or and we see it in many
countries around the world is Islamic
and otherwise
the big men of the community will often
look after multiple families because
especially if we go back you know back
to tribal days men would die all the
time they would leave families someone
would have to take care of these
families the idea that
the West can sit there and say no no
that's a bad thing I'm sorry you're
arguing with the majority of the world
and you're at least you're arguing with
the majority of history and I don't
personally think the West is a credible
source of of judging what is virtuous
and what is not Western Society is a
mess right now so that that would be my
first comment to that
but what I'd say is yeah at the end of
the day and that's what I like about
Islam as a man find out what fulfills
you and go and manifest that I'm not
going to pretend I have in any authority
to tell people how they should live
their lives I know what works for me and
I I've put effort in to execute on that
and I think any man should
should structure his life accordingly
one thing I reflect on a lot is building
your your custom-made reality and if
you're prepared to put in more work than
just about everybody if you have the
right Brothers around you if you don't
let yourself give in to mindful mindless
Pursuits like whether it's video games
or Hedonism or drugs or or meaningless
sex and you just focus on building
yourself as a man you can then create
that custom-made reality and I think for
a lot of successful men that does
involve multiple women Islam gives you a
healthy way to express that urge where
else is that urge actually expressed
healthily definitely not on Tinder that
doesn't that doesn't help you as a man
it damages a woman I mean if you're if
you're a masculine man and you are
intimate with a woman on a deep level I
believe that in a way you two are
connected for the rest of her life at
least and so I think it's if you're
again if you're the ideal sort of
masculine man you've got to be careful
who you're intimate with because perhaps
you'll you'll leave such an impression
on her that she's not going to be
fulfilled in future relationships I
think men have a lot to answer for in
terms of
I think Jordan Peterson put it well
there's no such thing as sex without
repercussions the idea that sex can just
be sex I mean look on on a shallow level
sure STD risks or energetic risks or
wasting time but I think on a deeper
level
especially if you're interacting with
you know a good woman who hasn't gone
out and been on a boat in Miami or
something you need to be careful as a
man because if you
you know and you connect on a deep level
but you don't plan to take care of her I
view that as irresponsible because
perhaps you are ruining her ability to
have fulfillment in future relationships
because she'll always look back to that
first sort of powerful intimate partner
that she had so
yeah I I hope I'm answering your
question but I I think what it comes
down to is men need to be accountable
to the fact that sexual relations and
intimacy have repercussions that can be
negative for the women and for this and
for society if you don't express your
urges for sexual Variety in a healthy
way and the only healthy way that I know
of is the Islamic context where you are
taking care of that woman and you take
responsibility for her welfare and that
of her family if you want to have that
sexual variety you take care of all the
families involved I got you later so you
have mentioned the the custom life you
were talking about this before how like
you created this for yourself
how does how does a man continue that
like okay look so what I'm trying to ask
is like
uh any man can essentially start doing
the things necessary yeah but then it's
like at some point you might lose the
drive or you might lose the focus you
might get distracted because you live in
a world full of distractions so what's
the best yeah yeah 100 so what's the
best advice from your own life from your
own like experience
okay well I don't pretend to be someone
who can I mean I'm new to to speaking
publicly I can only speak to what works
for me
um there's a few key things one is
maintaining uh that mindset of gratitude
every day when I when I pray in the
Masjid I always and focused on the
Gratitude aspect I mean in in a time
where we have
your family's children stuck under
Rubble in turkey and in Syria how can
you not be anything other than grateful
if you're not stuck under Rubble in
turkey or Syria like keeping that
perspective I think is very valuable and
on those lines how can you not be
motivated
if you're aware of how grateful you are
here we are sitting in the best country
in the world around Brothers we respect
doing meaningful work how can you not
feel that fire to keep going so this
idea of losing losing motivation brother
my challenge is getting to sleep at
night because I've got too much
motivation and so when you when you as a
man when you get to that level where you
can turn your time into into money into
meaningful learning into meaningful
impact in life the one thing you don't
have is enough time and that's so I
think
keeping motivation is not an issue as
long as you stay grateful you have
brothers around you having that
masculine accountability like if you
guys start slipping and then shaytan's
whispering in your ear your brother's
going to catch you and say hey man you
spent a little too much time on that
PlayStation don't you think you could
use that energy in more more meaningful
ways you know and that's that's Tate's
whole message there so the Gratitude
piece the masculine accountability
through Brotherhood but I also think
when you get to the level where you're
running multiple businesses where you've
got you know hundreds of people working
for you you've got to prioritize Health
man I've had some major health issues in
my in my life with my back from from
army days to this day it's a challenge
the one thing that I think a lot of men
who are really on their hustle they
forget is health I mean
nothing is is worthwhile without your
health and so I think that's one thing
you need to keep that going you've got
to prioritize health
but also at a certain level when money
is easy
you're looking for purpose you know when
you've got the money right when you've
got you know your brothers around you
when you've got meaningful work you want
to give back and that's why you see a
lot of wealthy people doing philanthropy
and so take you know obviously a lot
more wealthy than me but I'm
alhamdulillah I'm financially in a good
position you're looking for ways to give
back that's not just again anyone can
just donate money to a charity you want
to take that time that effort that
expertise that you have and make a
meaningful impact on society and to me
when you're when you've transitioned in
the I mean men Go in different levels
first you want to get that money right
then you want to get that status that
accolades I've got a master's degree of
I've got a BJJ black belt whatever then
you get to that next level where hang on
I've built all this what can I do with
it how can I give it back and I'll be
completely honest for me the money piece
is easy now that that's so that's no
longer a metric of success oh more money
how how is that if you're past the point
of worrying about money how does more
money mean anything it doesn't what you
can do without the way you can give back
that's what keeps that motivation going
so I think the yeah that the Gratitude
mindset that the Brotherhood piece the
the continual focus on health because
that can fall over that can get in the
way of you really you know leaving your
mark on the world but then finding a
meaningful way to give back
that's where you'll forever maintain
that motivation Okay so
how does one actually find the
Brotherhood
so I mean look I could give a plug for
war room because that helped me a lot so
the tape brand is a good filter of men
most men when they see Tate oh the car
is going to be rented or those women
it's just transactional it's hard when
you see someone like Tate because he's
achieved so much it shines a light on
what you have or haven't achieved in
your life but for those few men who see
what he's achieved and the way he's
created that custom-made reality and
think you know what I wouldn't mind
being around that there is his community
of the war room where there's thousands
of men who are driving each other who
any city in the world you've got guys
who are you know pushing with their
Fitness pushing with their finances who
have Traditional Values who are
respectful men who are Professionals in
in what they do you can tap into that
resource globally so the warm is one way
I also find fight clubs to be a great
place to find Brotherhood you know if
you you fight with men you build that
that Brotherhood military obviously is a
great way to find Brotherhood although
you'll often pay for that with you know
your body or a lot of people pay for
that with their mind I don't necessarily
encourage putting your life on the line
for a government that doesn't care about
you
um so I wouldn't say that that's a way
but also I think if you're
if you're a practicing Muslim and you're
injecting yourself into the community by
you know doing what you can to support
your mustard or support you know local
Islamic initiatives or Charities I think
you will gravitate towards people doing
similar things and you will find a
Brotherhood there as well that'd be the
different ways I should find it that
Brotherhood thing is so key I often say
next to health Brotherhood is the most
valuable form of wealth because
with a relationship partner a man can
can help encourage a woman to be the
sort of woman he wants right but you
know it's a partnership but with a
brother you can't really you can't
really like he's either about it or he's
not you know one man can't really
create his ideal brother in another man
that's a you know we might be Crossing
some lines there
um that's more about you know man woman
relationships finding men who you can
really say you know what you're on the
same frequency as me you have the same
values as me you have the same drive as
me let's let's spend a lot of time
together and Conquer together that's a
very valuable thing I know a lot of
ultra and even Ultra ultra high net
worth individuals a lot of money but no
Brotherhood I would not swap my life for
those theirs I know so many ultra high
net worth individuals who don't have
real brothers around them who've got a
lot of yes men around them they've got a
lot of people trying to take their
resources you guys who have an actual
Brotherhood of men around you who you
respect who you care about you're on
your on your grind together that's
that's a form of wealth which I view is
a lot more important than money a lot
more meaningful yeah Priceless really
speaking about bro I'm going bro I feel
like you guys accepted no man I just
want to highlight what he said because I
feel like this people will hear this
right
I've heard this message and it's like
it's not until I'm like here right now
with all of you brothers that I feel
that that fire inside of me is like I'm
looking at you I'm looking at what
you're doing I'm literally asking myself
like
what the hell am I doing yeah like I'm
over here making all these damn excuses
to not go further to not put in words I
just
be where I'm at and just be like content
and happy there's nothing wrong with
being content happy but it's like
it has to do with the environment has to
do with the brothers 100 and I want to
highlight that because it's like even
though I'm seeing that message even
though we're all seeing that messages
it's not until you're actually
surrounded by it that like you can
really like internalize it and that's
that's the thing when you internalize
something that's where the real change
occurs 100 and on that the concept of
direct transmission when you're around
someone like the Tates who are on such a
high frequency we train we we work
there's this constant idea of of getting
the most out of every day that has to
pick up your energy like it's I I
believe the
social Neuroscience talks about the
concept of an emotional economy you know
if you get on that Subway in London and
everyone's all depressed you're going to
feel depressed right if you're around a
bunch of Fighters who are high
testosterone and a in in the ring doing
the thing you're going to feel more oh
I've got to get in there more driven we
are we are pack animals we're affected
by those who are around us so being I'm
I'm very fortunate to have been around
the tape so much because that has awoken
that that fire in me and the masculine
accountability they've put on me hey man
you could do this more you could do that
more and I do it to them everyone picks
each other's up picks each other up you
all as a group of men become a higher
frequency in terms of your your output
in terms of your motivation There's real
power there man and I put it to you that
if you're in any way is any man out
there lacking or feeling their lack
motivation you need to spend more time
around manual respect that's the key
that's that's endless motivation because
your brother's gonna say hey man well
you you're good at Call of Duty why not
get a rifle and learn how to train in
the real world you know you like you
like watching boxing get in the ring
yourself you know go through that trial
and face your fears it's yeah I think
masculine accountability and Brotherhood
I know so many rich men who are in a
household and a daily reality that is
not fulfilling because they lack
Brothers they lack physicality they lack
traditional Dynamics in their
relationship and that their woman
doesn't respect them and so the whole
house is just constant arguments and and
negative banter is terrible I would not
swap my lives with the vast majority of
very rich men out there because I have
Brotherhood I have meaningful work I
have physicality of sorts on a
day-to-day basis my reality is extremely
fulfilling I have built my custom
reality without hundreds of millions of
dollars you don't need that as someone
who grew up poor I was very driven to
make money just so I didn't I wasn't
worried about being hungry but once
you've done that the forms of wealth
that you chase are a lot more meaningful
and Brotherhood is up there with the
best of them this reminds me of Hadith
or the poster still mentioned that good
company is better than your company but
no company is better than Bad Company oh
I like that see look at this man there's
so much to learn it's amazing so a lot
of the people that are wondering what do
I do I don't have a good company that's
of this if you're alone it's still
better than having no company or having
bad company isn't it
um but that does bring me to my actual
question that what are your thoughts of
the Prophet salallahu because coming
into it maybe you had some preconceived
notion maybe you had this narrative and
now actually studying him and and even
if you don't know him too well but just
what you've learned so far about him
masculinity being the leader of the
ummah what do you think about that well
yeah I think it's a great question thank
you and I think for those who um
curious about Islam
um the life of them of the prophet
Allah is that right yep okay excellent
this is a great end to really realize
hang on this man was a leader this man
was a warrior this man was a patriarch
this is a guy who or a man who
you you can't help but respect the more
you read about his his lived experience
was so extreme by so many measures he
achieved so much to me it's it's the
ultimate masculine role model and if if
we're looking to be that if we're
looking to be the man why not study and
try to emulate the man so I think in
terms of a masculine leader I think
people don't realize that those who you
know aren't familiar with Islam don't
realize how impressive a man
he was as a masculine leader who if you
want a fanboy on anyone don't pick some
Hollywood actor don't pick some NBA
player who throws a ball around who
cares have a look at a real Warrior a
real patriarch who has real lived
experience and insights that can
actually benefit your life I don't know
why people go to these football games
and cheer and wear a t-shirt with some
other man's name on their back who can
yes how is that benefiting you in life
take that energy study Prophet Muhammad
and actually get some benefit from on a
personal level so yeah I think that's a
great in into understanding Islam and
why he is so respected I think that the
more you study his life too you
understand how wide and sports it was in
terms of all the examples that we have
as human beings to have them as a role
model because he's lived as a husband to
one wife he's lived as a husband to
multiple wives we have in terms of
tactical combat in terms of business in
terms of moral character in terms of
Allah putting Allah first in terms of
how he gave money who he helped his
emotional intelligence his dominance his
character there's there's no doubt that
he is the most learned about men in
history that we know more about him than
we know about any other man in history
and I think it's a blessing from Allah
that he gave us the perfect example the
best of creation and then also didn't
just limit it to oh here's something we
know about him or he's something else
but we know in detail in descriptive
detail with authentic verifiable sources
time and time and again in almost any
realm of of or Avenue of Life about him
and we can take that and just
replicate it we can take that and use
them as a role model and I like that I
think to your point it wasn't you know
it wasn't just about being a warrior or
a leader conqueror he was also highly
empathetic highly compassionate highly
socially intelligent so yeah when you
look at that that concept of that
well-rounded masculinity there are many
different ways you can be a masculine
man if you want to emulate one masculine
role model show me a better example so I
think and the fact that what 1400 years
later everyone's still like whoa this
guy
was was demand
to me says a lot so yeah I
if I didn't have so many people who
worked for me and if I didn't respect
the people I work with so much I would
retire from work and I would focus on
studying Islam studying the Prophet
Muhammad
you know chess being you know
maintaining Fitness that would be enough
for me there's so much to learn and the
more I learn about it the more I get
hungry to learn more I really feel I
could devote many years in my life into
into this field of study and it wouldn't
be a chore in any anyway there's real
power here I think people don't realize
that there's there's a reason why so
many Muslims all around the world say
the same words at the same time facing
in the same direction there's power
there man it's not purely logically
purely even selfishly
why not tap into that power if you want
to be the best man that you can be and
if you want to get the most fulfilling
Human Experience from this life it's I
wish I had more time
to focus on my learning in this field oh
bless you I I even it reminds me of all
the old classical ancient Scholars of
Islam you know the best Scholars of our
time 1400 years ago 1300 years ago a lot
of them were asked on their deathbed
like what do you regret doing you know
these are people that dedicated like
decades to learning Islam
and I'm talking 50 60 years of full-time
not like us half-assing it and majority
of them they replied that I wish I just
started sooner if only I had started a
little bit sooner if only I started even
more years ago and we're out here just
you know full on the gas barely for like
what an hour a week two hours a week
reading a Hadith once a day maybe even
once a week thinking it's enough putting
on an Instagram story
but these were people that just wish ah
if only the 60 70 80 years of full-time
dedication if only I did more yeah wow
and that's that's what I find so
interesting in that there is so much to
learn and there's it's it's more than a
book it's more than a series of prayers
it's a code to life that it's almost
like a rabbit hole that doesn't have an
end to it and I I don't think my
enthusiasm is is passing I really
believe that I will stay motivated to
continue to learn simply because the
more I learned the more I go whoa I see
the best parts of me in this I see what
I want to be as a man I see what I think
men should be and women should be and
Society should be in this how does that
not motivate you to continue to look
into it and it's it's again I said this
earlier
time and time again over the last 15
years living in the Middle East across
all all you know areas of the Middle
East The Men Who I respected the most
were the ones who really took their
relationship with God seriously
doesn't that just tell you that by
following Islam sincerely genuinely
putting in the effort not just words but
actions you will be a good man you'll be
a man who is worthy of respect from your
fellow man if that's not a worthwhile
way to spend your time on this planet
then show me what is it's pretty simple
as well absolutely and linking like the
last few topics together
like not just nowadays as Islam such a
beautiful you know transformative you
know pill I guess people can take and
accept but if you look at the you know
the life the prophet Allah a great way
to tell his success and and to weigh his
success is from what he left behind look
at the men who came out of the society
this was a tribalistic society you and
you and me and you would not get along
you know you would be you would have
your tribe he'd have his his Bengali
tribe you'd have your Puerto Rican tribe
out of my Palestinian tribe you know I'd
have my sunburn tribe yeah
we wouldn't get along we'd be fighting
each other like crazy he brought this
Society people who literally have been
at War for like a decade or more
together and they loved each other for
the sake of Allah because Allah says in
the Quran indeed the Believers are about
brothers you know they took this
seriously and when he passed away peace
and blessing be upon him what happened
Islam expanded up to the borders of
China based all over Africa and then
nowadays all over the globe from one man
peace and blessing be upon him who lived
1400 years ago in Arabia that's how
significantly he transformed these
people murderers you know if people want
to talk about war mongers
his War tactics are still being
implemented today you know I don't know
if you know about that as a military man
but if you study his War tactics these
things are still being implemented today
he's the only person who actually
contributed to the prophet peace be upon
him getting injured because this was
before he accepted Islam this man he
flanked the Muslims in the Army and the
that wasn't what I won but some of the
people didn't listen to the instructions
what kind of terrain was this was this
mountain or desert or where was this
happening this is in the desert but
there is mountainous as well okay so
long actually let me explain it because
I think you'd appreciate this the
prophet peace be upon him he had uh
younger men who were archers he put them
on on a hill or a Mountaintop it sees
that High Ground yeah exactly he's like
whether you see us winning and
collecting the war booty or you see us
dying and getting slain do not leave
this mountain top right that's what he
instructed them to do
the enemies came they started fighting
the enemy started to flank and leaf the
Muslims were winning the people the
archers on the top didn't listen to the
process they came down with the Muslims
so they lost The High Ground the
advantage and their whole back was open
to a flank now because they didn't have
that High Ground Advantage another
another uh group from the opposing Army
came around and flanked them from the
back so they got pincered basically in
between two mountains they got pincered
interesting yeah the process of me got
injured in that people actually thought
the prophet died of the that battle that
those were the rumors going around you
know the uncle the prophet died in that
battle many Grace the hobby or sahaba
died at the Battle and this man Khalid
he was the arbitrator of that he later
accepted Islam you know this this murder
of Muslims at one point
and faster you know he asked the prophet
you know can you ask Allah to forgive me
can you ask God to forgive me he's like
don't you know that Islam forgives all
sins you know just like that he switched
he started fighting for the Muslims
subhanallah it is it's when you talk
about that especially I appreciate the
the anecdote but the fact that one man's
actions could
civilize warring groups that's pretty
wild that's and back then we were pretty
animalistic one could argue human nature
still is to this day yeah and I'd like
to tie into that with the Brotherhood
that I've experienced having reverted to
Islam is real I had one guy who I mean I
can't contact him unfortunately was on
Twitter he said hey I just wanna from
Saudi I want to send you a thank you
um and he sent me these beautiful books
and all these beautiful like you know
things from Saudi I've had guys in in
the Moscow I don't know say hey man I
noticed you're praying can I recommend
this like strangers coming up with real
Brotherhood yeah like it's not a joke
the Brotherhood in Islam is no joke but
I think it's like many things in life
what you put into it you get out of it
you know so it's yeah it's
I think anyone living without Islam is
is missing out on a serious
um
would you call it a competitive
advantage in terms of being the best
human that you can be or having the best
lived experience you can have it's it's
it's such a it's such a boost I I
already live a pretty fulfilling life
I'm not gonna lie I have created my own
custom-made reality but this on top of
it is just a whole nother level of
of experience for me to be grateful for
it's incredible and the prophet system
had emotional intelligence EQ in a whole
nother level that's interesting so can
you tell me more about that yeah so like
see the story about Khalid right before
he converted Khalid basically had this
pretext that I will never be forgiven
I'm not good enough to be a Muslim and
then when they came to him and asked you
know like you know he thinks he can't
he's like I believe Khaled Ben Walid is
too smart he's too he's too what was it
roaming yeah the processarily he was
basically like you know how has he not
accepted Islam he's too smart to not
realize this he's too smart like he
always saw the good in people this was a
man that was so Fearless but when it
came to his wives and kids for example
one of his wives when she would drink
from a cup and he would drink from the
same cup he would lift up the cup and
then he would rotate the cup to drink
exactly from where she drank
subtle things like that just to show
that he cares or when she was basically
on her Menzies right she would basically
you know be with him in bed and then she
would leave to basically go to the
washroom and then he would mention
because girls feel you know a little
insecure and a little bit like sensitive
on their on their Menzies and he would
tell her when you come back make sure
you come back and and lay with me even
closer things like that sort of things
like that there was this one time where
the Prophet Muhammad alaihi wasallam uh
he went to this funeral this woman uh I
think it was her husband her husband or
she was a mother okay she was a mother
she talked about it uh her son had died
and he went to basically like give his
condolences and you know like give us
some I'm not I was about to say passion
no he's not giving her passion but
condolences right so he goes over to her
and then she's upset and she's yelling
and she's cursing the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam I believe she
didn't know he was a prophet yeah she
just thought it was just she just
thought it was some random guy so she's
over here cursing him that like her
son's death is because of him and all
this stuff and anyone in the right mind
would have been like do you know who
you're talking to
but he stayed calm and then after she
was done and she got everything out he
gave his nasiha which is advice and then
he just said to salaams and left didn't
even say that he was the prophet
Muhammad he walked away and then one of
the sahaba came up to him like do you
know who you were talking to and then
she found out that that was the prophet
Muhammad sallam and because she saw his
character there's another story when he
was giving a like a lecture in like
Jamal or like a samsala and you know
during the sermon he felt like someone
you know tugging at his back very
aggressively and this is like this
Companions of the Prophet peace be upon
him they don't take that stuff lightly
they don't take anyone disrespecting him
so they're like getting heated and the
guy keeps tugging it the prophet saws
doesn't even react he turns his head
very slowly looks at the man and he very
calmly responds how can I help you and
the man is he had a smile and the man uh
asked uh responds to the prophet some
very heated saying you know this this
place where we live this part of town
it's like this is what's going on and
these are the problems that you're not
going to do anything and without
hesitation he said okay let's go let's
see what let's see what needs to be done
okay it's a very compassionate in a
sense
I swear we can go on like all night
there's so much to learn it's wild it
really is it just goes to show that what
makes a real man is this balanced
rounded masculinity this positive
masculinity we have a lot of movements
today like you know you got a red pill
and pickup and all this and I think
there's there's truth in all of these
movements right but we need to
understand where these movements come
from do they come from Divine Revolution
and perfect laws or do they come from a
lot of time frustrated reactionary
movements yeah it's a nice way to put a
frustrated reactionary movements that's
exactly it this makes me want to ask you
what are your thoughts on red pill I
look red pill helped me a lot
um get out of a very unhealthy marriage
I realize from Reading roller to
Massey's book the rational mail that I
was effectively being exploited yeah and
that I had every right as a man to say
hang on I deserve better than this I
deserve a partner who actually cares
about my health cares about my
well-being and isn't just you know
essentially using me for resources and
security so I think red pill definitely
has its its place and I mean I'm in
touch with Rolo I've said to him hey man
your book changed my life thank you for
that
but I think red pill will help you
understand what's wrong but it won't
give you an answer as to how to fix it
does that make sense 100 100 and and for
me I think anyone who puts a lot of
energy into the red pill
put energy into making yourself a more
capable man instead put energy into into
I mean yes be aware of how relationships
especially in the modern day and age can
become negative and and be aware of you
know toxic people but it's not just
women toxic men be aware of toxic people
you know and be very conscious of how
you set up a relationship and and being
clear about what you expect from her and
you know clear about understanding what
she expects from you and so on
um but I think at the end of the day if
you go with the traditional values and
you find a woman who also wants
Traditional Values and you're you're
really focusing on being the best man
that you can be and and being that
patriarchy provides and protects and and
not just financially at a certain point
the finances thing isn't isn't the issue
giving time to to the woman you care
about giving that real I feel
something's not right in you let's talk
about it no no everything's fine no
really I can feel something what's up
and then you find out there's stuff
that's been sitting there for a week
being that man who really cares about
his woman if you if you have
if you're on your grind if you're on
your mission if you're Mission focused
with the right man around you and you've
found a woman who wants what you want
from relationship I don't think all that
red pill stuff is necessary I think red
pill is very useful if you're in a
western relationship as a man and you
feel inside hang on I'm giving all of
this yet I don't get anything back sure
get across the red pill make changes
enjoy that divorce process it's a mess
it's not fun for anybody but then go and
create a more healthy relationship so
yeah red pill definitely useful for men
to realize they're being exploited by by
a system or by an individual or by a
toxic person as as unfortunately a lot
of people are nowadays there's a lot of
narcissism there's a lot of users a lot
of takers not givers
but from I don't think it has any any
benefit or application for creating that
positive alternative
and and I think Traditional Values is
the way I think religion in in terms of
the Islamic approach if you if you want
that multiple uh woman scenario is the
way to find the positive answers to go
and create that that positive
relationship I think red pill is pretty
negative overall which it needs to be
you're studying what's gone wrong but it
doesn't give you that way to fix it yeah
it's a great way to put it and you know
I think the parliament red pill has
become prescriptive you know this whole
like pickup culture and like basically
let your wife give your wife the
impression you don't care about her
because you let her do whatever all
these you know Horrible Very unislamic
things by the way
um you know these concepts are actually
being pushed nowadays by by red pill and
that's why you know it's developed this
kind of black pill and mgtow and all
these things that are a little more in
cell like because this is just some of
them are just pure hatred towards women
we want nothing to do with them Islam
has nothing like that bro in Islam one
of the things you're saying he said
before he passed away peace and blessing
be upon him was take care of your woman
take care of your woman take care of
your women that was something that he
was big on you know and you saw how he
took care of his wives and you also saw
how he you know kind of disciplined them
in a way there was a time where all of
his wives were kind of giving him a
difficult time and he he took 27 days or
so away from all of them but at the same
time Islam gives rights to them that
you're not allowed to neglect them
you're not allowed to basically go more
than three months without being with
them you know intimately in that stuff
these things are there to protect both
the man and the woman and a lot of a lot
of that is completely missing from the
west and then again I'd ask the question
for those who are following the red pill
or whatever how's that working out for
you
seriously that's the ultimate Challenge
again to the wokism the religion the
followers of the religion of wokism
how's that working out for you are you
fulfilled are you happy and I laugh when
I hear some of this red pill stuff she's
not yours it's just your turn oh man I'm
sorry if you were a good man and you are
taking care of a good woman she would
never dream of going on to another man
and I can say that with full Authority
and lived experience so it's I I think
the the people who are really believing
that red pill if the red pill is their
religion they're also missing out on the
best version of their themselves and the
best
path in terms of a lived experience and
Islam gives them guidance and answers
there so what would you say to the
person that's like okay I hear you but
where do I start you know what about
Islam is you know okay well I'd say
first of all to the mgtail guys if you
need to take time out of dating and
focus on getting your money right your
Fitness right you know your Brotherhood
right excellent I think
I wouldn't even call it mgtow I call it
focusing on yourself as a man and
building your capabilities that's a very
positive thing so I'm all for that but
I'd say a man is happiest when he has a
loyal giving caring partner next to him
because brother the one thing brothers
can't give you is feminine healing
energy and also women encourage you to
to enjoy life like women are much more
aesthetic yeah you can tell if a house
is a man's own only house or if there's
a woman there it's just like it's a more
beautiful environment there's a woman
there walking along a street you know a
man won't notice the sunset or the
beautiful trees of a woman will say hey
baby look at this and then you
experience more of the beauty of life
with it with a good woman next to you
yeah um so yeah I'm not sure if I'm
answering your question there brother
but that's that would be my answer to
the mgtow guys yeah that's beautiful he
said I mean even in my experience like I
I handila you know actually renovated a
big part of my house for my wife I
literally like I put up walls I put up
doors but man when she decorated that
thing it was a whole other universe and
there's an energy behind that when a
woman has made a house into a home it
gives you that sense of you know I'm out
in the world doing combat dealing with
you know business people trying to shock
me whatever or in my line of work actual
combat you come home to a place that has
that feminine energy that peace that
beauty I wouldn't buy art and put it on
the wall I don't care yeah when you have
a woman who has an eye for these things
it your home becomes your sanctuary and
that's the the concept of the female
healing you I really do believe that and
I've read up on this the the back in the
day the the sort of optimal thing was
tribes of about 150 people as per the
sociologist of some sort or a historian
and the men would go out and they'd hunt
you know that they'd they'd fight they'd
do what men do then they'd come back to
the camp and be around the woman and
that's when they'd be in the feminine
frame uh you know testosterone levels
would lower you'd be less tense you'd
get some meat back on from eating
properly you'd have intimate relations
you'd feel calm relaxed then you go back
out with your men again back out you
know beyond the wire so to speak up and
if we bring that to today's sort of
context a house where you don't have a
woman giving you that okay you can relax
now this is a safe environment there's
no combat here we're here to make you
feel better to lift you up I I think
you're really missing out on on on
[Music]
a gift from Allah which is a good giving
woman adds so much to life it really
does let me see one more thing it's
amazing because it's not just good for
you it's not just good for the man it's
good for the kids you know now the kids
have a good strong masculine diet and a
loving compassionate empathetic mother
literally that's the key to success for
a kid and if you if you see how
important it is for a for a kid to have
a good strong man and a loving
compassionate mother bro
sometimes makes me want to cry bro how
many kids who nowadays you know they're
depressed they're sad they're upset they
don't know what they want to do in life
and they don't have father figures you
know or their their mother abandon them
or their mother neglected them or the
mother always put what she wanted what
she believed on to them growing up and
did not care about the model it's a very
depressing thing and that's what you see
with narcissism the more narcissistic a
person is the less empathetic they're
going to be the less empathy they'll
show towards their child's learning and
needs and that's why I think I'm
genuinely scared for future generations
and why parent parenting's hard man I
mean if you guys got kids no yet okay
soon inshallah but don't rush because
it's a lot of work yeah definitely if
you can just give a kid an iPad and
they're done if you're a narcissistic
person who'd rather get dopamine hits
from social media that's what you're
going to do so I think the quality of
parenting is going downhill all around
the world and you see that more and more
with these liberals these Progressive
types these women who have to be back in
the office six weeks after giving birth
I think that's horrible why would why
would you be pulled away from something
you'd birthed an extension of yourself
as a woman your child so you can go back
and what help raise the share price for
a multinational that doesn't care about
you I think it's a very unnatural way of
living I think it's really sad and two
yeah two ways I wanted to tie you know
sum up the red pill thing you know even
though that's taking the personal but
I've never seen a movement so obsessed
with getting women to think that they
don't care about them but they're
spending extraordinary amounts of time
focused on Modern women it's true it's
like the whole don't text her back act
like you're busy but then you're out
here just laying in bed thinking about
what she's doing and all this nonsense
is she with another guy she'd like bro
this this stuff is so foolish this
number one and then number two the thing
with red pill is
at the end of the day it just leads you
to a place where you are headed to
nihilism because the things that these
people on Reddit and and red pill and
make tell that they're obsessed with is
just why are women like this why are
women like that female nature it's not
it's not your girl like you said she's
just your turn and then over time you
begin to resent women you don't actually
understand women you don't actually care
about women and red pill game will only
work on damaged women sure it will only
work on low quality women that you
shouldn't even want in your life to
begin with exactly so you're only
basically you're limiting yourself to
attracting only low quality women that
work for this red pill game that's trash
it's degenerate and all the good quality
Muslims that are out there you're
pushing them to the side almost like you
don't want them and I I think adding on
to that I think any kind of pickup
Artistry or any game or any of that
stuff I don't think it works on quality
women I don't think it works or if it
does it won't last okay so you know how
to trick a woman into getting her
clothes off you're not a man who can
take care of her emotionally physically
you know in terms of provisioning all
this all these men who want to get high
quality relationships and and they
channel that urge into game
that's only going to work with with
low-class women who are looking for some
sort of transactional strange if you
want a quality relationship with a woman
become a quality man it's so simple my
advice to any young man would be
until you've got your money right and
your Fitness right and your career right
and your your perspective on life dialed
in why are you even bothering with women
take that urge to spread your seed
everywhere and put it into your hustle
put it into your Fitness because it's I
mean did Freud say no I might be
misquoting here but
any meaningful action is is a result of
taking Sexual Energy and and
transmitting it or channeling it onto
non-sexual things
yeah I mean I I could be conflating him
with it another one another you know
famous psychologist or commentator of
some sort but at the end of the day yes
that the fury inside a young man to to
have sexual relations it's strong it's
fierce
take that to building yourself into the
best man you can be and anyone who's
born in the west especially you have
every option every every opportunity to
become wealthy early you know I mean I
buy early I mean in your 30s like it's
it's hard to build real wealth before
your sort of mid-30s I've found you know
generally speaking it's it's 35 onwards
when you really hit your stride that's
just what I've noticed unless you're in
Tech or software or nft something which
none of which I understand but yeah I I
really don't know why so many men are so
fixated on physical pleasure and game
and all this nonsense if you want a
quality woman or multiple quality woman
you've got work to do son channel that
energy into building who you are not
just spraying your seed into random
women who you don't even care about it's
so going back to what you said
because now you're talking about the
this like fire within the heavy you know
young man has so
you gave the example of back then where
we'll be going to war we'll be going
doing these things where it's like would
be around then maybe around brothers so
we would just have that testosterone
regime we'll come back and then our
woman it would bring that feminine
energy that feminine healing calm right
so let's say you're married you live in
the same household with the woman
obviously so
how would you go about working at home
if you had to work at home it's a tricky
one it really is a tricky one because I
I mean without getting too metaphysical
I really do believe men and women have
different energetic frequencies and I
think if you want to live in that
masculine frame and be Geared for
Conquest for maximum output for maximum
learning you know business gains
everything I don't think you want to be
around women all the time I mean for me
as a man am I going to get up and train
and work and hustle or am I going to
sleep in with a beautiful woman next to
me who you know I can share all sorts of
lovely emotions it's a tricky one right
so what I'd say is I think you of course
you can live I mean ideally you live
with your brothers and you like Andrew
and Tristan and they're always on their
grind sure but I understand that's not
realistic for most people then I think
you just need to be aware of the
temptation of oh it's warm here and it's
comfortable why would I get up at x
amount you know five in the morning for
five year or whatever and you just have
to hold yourself to account yes I'm
living around a woman yes there's
potential for me to slip into the
feminine frame Netflix lots of sex and
also when you're in a relationship with
a woman who truly cares about you you
cannot satiate her in with intimacy she
will always take more of your attention
and more of your intimacy there's no
stop to it so you need to be aware of
the fact that while that feels good as a
man I need to be focused on the
masculine frame which is Conquest which
is output which is building businesses
which is giving back to communities not
just oh it feels nice and warm in bed
here you know oh yeah let's watch
Netflix and and and just feel
comfortable I think a woman's role is to
make you not just work all the time and
I know I've been in positions before
I've just worked constantly in some
impacted my health so you need that
woman to bring you down but at the same
time you need to hold yourself to
account that you don't let her calm you
too much so that it gets in the way of
your output for example I'd say if you
have it for example like the way I do
now a games room Officer study that's a
man's room women don't come in there
that's where you do work when you've
done with your work then you can go into
the sofa and relax or you know do
whatever you do sit in the backyard with
your woman but I think it's if you want
to maintain that masculine frame ideally
you live with other men if that's not
realistic then you have your workspace
which is purely a masculine area for you
to focus on that masculine frame on that
output on that hustle that's how I'd
manage that yeah probably like working
outside of home yeah I mean I think that
helps too but our offices nowadays A
masculine frame environment I don't know
it's it's
I think if you really are a young if
you're a young man and you really want
to build something live with the men you
work with and just train and work and
grind and and don't give in a Temptation
Of course don't do drugs I view video
games as a form of drug you know avoid
all of that don't don't chase women more
than like one day a week or something
you know and just really focus on that
masculine frame and being output based
yeah
I think I think another important aspect
is understanding someone's obligations
like a man this is why Islam is so
beautiful because we have obligations
we're not allowed to sit around and be
losers right the prophet peace upon him
he said it's a beautiful Hadith he said
the strong believer is better and more
loved by Allah than the weak believer
but but there's good in everyone so we
should lift them basically of course but
and it's not just us things it's not
just physical strength right it's mental
strength it's emotional strength it's
spiritual strength it's it's Financial
strength it's you know strengthened what
exactly yeah
it's any kind of strength and the Hadith
goes on it tells us how to get strong as
well he says hold on tightly to that
which benefits you you know it could be
the gym it could be brothers could be
your work could be whatever and don't
become you know hopeless heartless and
that begs the question how would
somebody become hopeless he said if
something you know it comes to you in
the form of difficulty don't say man I
should have went here instead I should
have done that instead I should have
invested here and said right
you know this mentality is is is the
formula for success in life and as a
Muslim in this world and again tying it
to what I was saying before
understanding your obligations to get
better as a man to grow I think is what
what will say people from this this
comfortable lifestyle one one last thing
I want to say my teacher gave a lecture
on this maybe a year or two ago but it
stuck with me because it's so powerful
we look at any place where Comfort is
mentioned in in the Quran Hadith you'll
find it's linked to Hellfire eventually
interesting isn't that interesting yeah
and look at where discomfort is
mentioned right in any way shape or form
and look at how it's linked to Paradise
in heaven there's a prophet the Hadith
inshallah
where he said Allah he has veiled
um heaven with difficulty and he's
veiled jahannam Hellfire with Pleasures
there it is and then the modern day sort
of psychological interpretation of that
something written
1400 years ago is men need struggle to
grow we need that and also where do we
Bond where do you Bond most with men in
struggle we talk about especially with
the great Wars World War One World War
II there there was a World War One
veteran who was saying
men nowadays don't understand we loved
the man next to us in the trench we
would die for him and he would die for
us it was real love more than the love
you would experience with a woman
and of course it was a non-sexual thing
but he was saying the bond that they
formed in that struggle in the worst
periods of humanity that trench warfare
you know living in in the mud and dirt
for months surviving off bread and
cheese you know with artillery barrage
coming in that suffering leads to that
that bonding between men and one of the
things I love about fight Sports and the
reason why my son is a pretty committed
boxer and does his BJJ as well as that's
a healthy way to expose a man to
struggle and to risk enhanced it for him
to grow as a man what a fantastic system
in Life or for Life Islam is where it
says hey guess what you need to get up
five times a day and do something that
is not attached to Donya and that
reminds you of you know the greatness of
Allah
which reminds you to be grateful for
what you have that you need to be strong
to provide for your family you need to
be disciplined it's man the more I hear
about it and even this has been very
motivational the more I want to learn so
thank you guys and it also ties back
into what we're saying with Tate we can
come full circle now a lot of people
concerned about him but guess what this
is his struggle and he'll come out
stronger both of them will they'll come
out more more united as brothers more
focused on on what's real in life more
in touch with their faith more
more influential with which to set to to
project their positive message around
the world which I believe also will
bring a lot of people to Islam inshallah
I wanted you to share one more Hadith
before we go on when I believe it was
jibril Islam Gabriel Archangel Gabriel
he saw what Jannah was covered with
and he saw Hellfire and what that was
covered around do you want to say that I
just I can but I just don't remember the
end of it okay okay yeah so Allah he
created you know Heaven and Hell and he
created the angel jibril Gabriel peace
and bless me upon him and he told the
angel to go look at heaven right and
this is when it was first created
nothing it wasn't veiled with anything
it was just Jannah itself so he went
he's like I think everyone's going to
want to go here because he knew that
this is a place where people are
supposed to reside he's like I I know
people are going to want to be here
everyone's going to enter this place all
right who wouldn't then he saw you know
hell and he's like everyone's gonna stay
away from that place who who in the
right mind would want to go there and
then Allah like I mentioned he veiled
hell with with comfort and ease and he
veiled heaven with difficulty and
hardship so the angel he was like I now
I think everyone's gonna fall into hell
because they're gonna go down this
Rabbit Hole of comfort comfort and
they're gonna fall into hell yeah you
look at what heaven's filled with it's
the most
difficult the most treacherous the most
hard things in life to get there and
then you look at what what the glamor
and the glimpse of like Janam you know
Pleasures drugs sex everything that not
you know Haram sex obviously you guys
know what I'm talking about we have no
we're not shy about Intimacy in Islam
but you know instant gratification Cheap
Thrills and he's fearing like I fear
everyone will go to jahannam Just based
on just look at this who would who would
reject this willingly knowing that we
have enough Temptation super interesting
and again all of this is written so long
ago and it's still so relevant but it's
so clear incredible and I feel like this
mindset that life is a test and
everything is just a test that's such an
underrated formula to success in life
because if we really live every single
day wake up in the morning and anything
that happens any Calamity this is just a
test from Allah yeah any Temptation This
is just a test from Allah talk about I
mean all these mindset coaches out there
trying to give you the right mindset for
Life what is that
all these people trying to give you
mantras to read about what what is Salah
you they're positive mantras with which
to self-program your mind to be the
optimal version of yourself correct
there's so much power here so much power
absolutely subhanallah and um I was
going to say something man so my mind
it's getting too late for me but um you
need more Red Bull brother
I need my first one I've never done
drugs but oh I do like Red Bull
but yeah I I went on this kind of um
Journey asking a lot of different people
what their goal in life is every single
young man Under the Sun make money and
and blah blah blah and I when you dig
deep you know why do you want to make
money it's always
I want to be free I want to be
financially if I want to be free and I
ask them do you think that this is
something that you have decided for
yourself and they're like yeah you know
they're my goals I'm like but that's not
true you live in a capitalistic Society
where it's a rat race you are pushed
into the society where your your
objective is you're told your objective
is to make money you have to make money
to live right everyone around you is
making money and if you don't you're
seen as lesser you live in a liberal
Society where you need to go after your
Personal Pleasures you need to go after
your hedonistic valuables and all that
stuff you didn't decide it Society
decided it for you and tricked you into
thinking it's your own idea that's why
Islam is liberating people accept it you
have to actually say
you testify that's how you accept Islam
you believe it and then you testify it
and then you adopt it into your life
exactly and it's such a relief every
time that I pray I'm reminded again the
expression Allahu Akbar as I understand
it most people think it means God is
great but literally God is like the
biggest the largest if God is the
biggest the largest what are your
problems then nothing and so if we want
to talk about you know mindset hack to
release stress remind yourself five
times a day that God is the greatest and
your problems don't mean anything and
all these things it's it's such a
powerful frame with which to be content
and the most optimal version of yourself
it really is huge I have a question guys
yeah you guys are yawning and stuff oh
I'm on like three hours sleep a night
I've been working all day I'll work when
you guys to go where's the energy Lads
come on
I mean it's a very good question I don't
know having it I mean is that jet leg oh
cool we can blame the jet lag
the one thing I will say as well is as a
man you can build your muscle that is
your stamina with which to focus on work
I can work 20 hours a day for months on
end if I need to now my body will give
out I even know where where things start
to go wrong with my body but as a man as
I learned from the Tates you can build
your ability to bring laser-like focus
on a task for 20 hours a day and you
really can and once you're there
I think the Brotherhood thing the the
once you've got that fire once you're on
that frequency of endless work endless
work every hour I'm doing something
meaningful every hour I'm taking my
expertise and making money or benefiting
my people or my causes you can't help
but have that motivation so I put it to
you that
there is a there was a frequency you can
live as a human where being tired or
unfocused is not a thing it's not a
thing no matter how tired I am I'm still
laser focused on that task I put it to
you guys that you can continue to build
that muscle and to push each other to
work more to put more time it's a real
thing one of the things I learned from
the tapes you've got to put a foot on
the gas for the podcast you're right on
sure guys because we were literally
talking about this uh you know with uh
we'll have in the car that we're not
we're not doing as much as we could be
and I know alhamdulillah we're still
doing a lot and we we have a good
intention alhamdulillah but that's
something we really want to work on for
this coming year and onward inshallah
that we need to put our foot on the gas
even more 100 and this platform is great
and if at any point you guys need some
sort of backing I'd love to discuss that
what you're doing is very meaningful and
it's very genuine you're doing it from
the right place smash it get Global
again if you if you guys need some
funding let's chat like it's this is
important and you need to keep doing it
you really do it's why not
I know yes no literally yeah
this morning brother bro I see you yeah
we were in the car and he was bringing
up this uh this this whole thing about
us and what we're doing and he
highlighted like why are you guys just
like half-assing it why why you know
white Camp angry that you haven't
conquered with this platform that you
have with this Brotherhood that you have
exactly right take calls it fire blood
right why don't you have that fire Blood
let's just look at him look I wish we
could point the camera I wish we could
bro he said why aren't you conquering
and like ever since he said that I'm
like
why haven't I been gone why haven't we
been calling why haven't we why have we
only had like one toll on the gas
instead of the whole foot just slammed
down like that so it's like
the question that I really want to ask
look
realistically as Muslim men you know we
are encouraged it's Sunnah to get
married as early as possible as young as
possible Life as a man doesn't get real
satisfying until 35 and on that's when
you really hit you've got you've got
your network you've got your expertise
you're established but you still got
that energy to drive man I work three
times harder than I did in my 20s I'm so
much more fired up every day I wake up
more hungry before we get back into the
podcast we've got a very special
announcement as you can see we are here
in Masjid
father Muslim Brothers out there that
are trying to level up that game we have
our first drop coming out soon we have
200 pieces that are going to be released
within the strap so if that's something
you're trying to do then click the link
on the screen in the description box
down below to get 10 off on the drop day
which is March 31st and make sure to
check your email box so you can see if
you got the message check your spam
folder as well to see if you got the
message that way you can be on point and
be notified as soon as we release this
clothing on March 31st five percent of
all proceeds are going to building
Norway so make sure that you are
checking your email so that you can
confirm and be notified when we drop on
March 31st collection is going to be
called Victory impatience in honor of
Andrew and Tristan Tate for what they're
going through right now so let's make
Dua so that Allah releases them as soon
as possible and brings them out in the
best state that he can possibly bring
them out in and with that being said
let's get right back into the podcast
uh I can jump in bro what we're talking
about is unlocking that
that hunger everyone knows they should
do more how do you actually unlock that
into energy yeah yeah so uh like I was
saying I was giving the example of when
we were in the car with the brother of
Javier yeah and uh he said like why
aren't you conquering and I I said like
we got like one toe on the the gas like
SpongeBob bro instead of putting a full
foot and just slamming it like yamming
it just going straight forward instead
we're over here like oh no like we'll do
a little bit here a little bit there and
so not my question right every man in
Islam it's a Sunnah to marry as young as
possible so now if if as a man we get
married and we live in a household with
this woman
you had given the example of what you
can do having like that separate room
where it's like it's yours like you go
in there you're working you don't come
out masculine frame room yeah but then
you also give the idealistic example of
like living with your brothers how could
one tie these two together I think what
you're doing right now Lads trips you
know we're going to go to this country
whether it's we're going to mountain
bike across this range or we're going to
go to this fight camp in Thailand for a
week or we're going to go to you know to
buy into a series of podcasts go on
those Lads trips I mean does that not
replicate the olden days the men would
head out from the tribe they'd go to
battle then they'd come back and relax
and again if and again I don't want to
be too presumptuous but if money is an
issue it's not an issue if you guys need
funding for travel and we can cut this
out whatever tell me that's that's what
you guys are doing is real consider
yourselves having corporate backing like
it's if that's an obstacle then tell me
and we'll just talk about it like it is
if you're giving your best to it I would
love to fund what you guys are doing
it's real it's really a meaningful but
also tying into what we were saying now
before the camera cup
in your 20s you think you're working
life gets satisfying as a man from like
35 onwards if you've done all the right
things to get there I work now so much
harder and so much more efficiently and
have so much more impact than in my 20s
I'm 10 times more effective as a man
than I was I've got my Global Network
I've got that made man status where I
have influence I've got supportive
family members supportive Brothers
around me
the reason why you might feel you're not
your most impactful self now is you're
still early in the game brother when you
get to your 30s and and a lot of men in
their 40s will say the same that's when
you really pick you because you've got
all that experience but you've still got
that energy and you've got your Global
Network you've got your brothers you've
cut out the toxic influences in your
life you've got good women around you
taking care of you that's when you will
really make your mark on this universe
so you're still building yourself up to
that you'll get more if you're living
your life right you'll get more
motivated to work as you approach
mid-30s not less the idea of I remember
back in the day I used to even in Army
days when I joined when I was very young
straight out of school I'd see some of
these guys you know running up hills
being really life being it and I thought
you know I wish I was that guy I
realized now they were all 30s and above
like as a young man you're still trying
to find that motivation when you get to
the point where you can turn one hour
into x amount of dollars or one hour
into x amount of changing a man's life
for the better that's your motivation
but it takes time to build that value so
you can be that guy so your hunger your
fire will grow as you get older it's if
you're doing the right thing and you've
got the right people around you the
motivation will come with time because
you become more impactful as a man each
minute of your time can leave more
positive impact on on your Society on
your brothers on your on your bank
balance so you get more and more
motivated about it isn't that crazy
because like yesterday we went to the
big Grand mask in Abu Dhabi and me and
the Army were just having an epiphany
after Salah and we were just like bro
what have we really done
like when it's all said and done what
have we really done in this life but
your perspective it's very calming and
refreshing because it's not necessarily
we're doing the wrong thing we just we
haven't given it enough time yet and
you're building the foundation to become
the most impactful version and you said
the correct you said that off camera
like life gets fun after 35. oh it gets
fulfilling when you're a made man when
you put that work in and when you got
your money right for the longest of
times I was very insecure about money
because I grew up in situations where I
was at times physically hungry where I
was that poor kid getting picked on
because I had the crappy clothes now I
have the Custom Clothes the customer
house the custom cars alhamdulillah I
have a custom lifestyle life gets real
fulfilling when you put in that effort
but man it's years it's Decades of work
to become that man
[Music]
if you guys made it this far you got to
leave the matrix real quick you got to
unplug yourself yes and become that
custom lifestyle designer as shooter
said man I just want to say bro like I
love you so much
appreciate you brother appreciate it I
thought he told you like before this
like I didn't have that masculine I
don't think any of us did bro I think
the vast majority of men didn't have a
man who was really about it and that's
where the tights were very fortunate
they had an extremely masculine man
extremely principled man who put those
those values into them but that that's
the value of Brotherhood we can we can
be masculine role models for each other
in a society in a world where masculine
role models are pretty much you know a
Dying Breed we can bring that up in each
other I think it's quite meaningful yeah
excellent well I'd like to end by saying
don't follow me on social media no I'm
serious I don't have access to my
Twitter because after the you know the
whole kerfuff with that and I had to put
my Instagram on private because there's
so many people making disgusting
comments towards me and and family and
all this sort of stuff so do not follow
me on social media
most people want to give a shout out I
say don't bother
um when in the real world instead
honestly being off Twitter gave me an
extra two hours in a day wow like it's
that stuff's all toxic man it really is
absolutely when in the real world I
think there's a lot of people who are
especially when I had Twitter
um
writing saying hey I'm concerned about
Tate what can I do Tate wants you to
continue building the best version of
yourself
so all those people who want to write
him letters or want to do something he's
all right he's fine people should take
that energy and focus on bettering
themselves that's take that State's
whole message use every moment of every
day to become the best version of
yourself so all these people are worried
about Tate that's distraction focus on
becoming the best version of yourself
that's what tape would say to anybody
should should they ask and that's what
you want for us right
that's exactly and what I'd also say to
everyone out there who's who's
considering uh or who's driven to become
the best version of themselves and to
have the most fulfilling life you need
to look at Islam not not necessarily
from a religious perspective or from an
emotional perspective but from a purely
logical perspective if your goal is to
live the best life you can and be the
most impactful and positively
contributing to family to society a man
that you can be you have to look at
Islam otherwise you are you are you're
missing out you're missing out on a
powerful
life accelerator if you will a powerful
system with which to get the most out of
this life and to give back the most
beautiful so many people think they have
life figured out and like why do I need
Islam I'm happy but I feel like they
just haven't gotten too deep into that
black hole of Hedonism yet yeah and a
lot of people they I don't know about I
can't speak on behalf of everyone but
myself definitely brother Angel maybe
even around me definitely will hop too
that it wasn't until we were at our
lowest points in our life that Allah
gave us Allah guided us isn't that
interesting yeah I like how the wisdom's
coming out at one in the morning for me
Islam came at the highest point in my
life every every no every day in the
Masjid the vast majority of what I say
when I speak to
um Allah is gratitude I I ask for
nothing more for myself I have
everything I could ever want that's when
I found Islam because when you have
everything where and again I'm not
trying to flex or anything but when
you've got the money right the status
who cares you know when you've got that
custom-made lifestyle
you're gonna ask what's next and a
direct line to Allah
is the most powerful and
fulfilling thing you can have money
won't give you that status won't give
you that Cars toys and women experiences
quite the opposite a lot of the time so
for me is it interesting you say a lot
of people find Islam at the darkest time
of their life I found it at the best
time in my life and it still adds
incredible value
thank you brother I mean it's important
that we have people of all you know
backgrounds all Realms all statuses in
life come except Islam I actually think
it's it's I think it's very interesting
that someone like you and someone like
Angie would accept Islam given that they
have everything you know in this world
it shows it shows a lot of humility
actually people I don't know why they
like to attribute and she accepting
Islam to something negative I think it's
something very positive because how much
does he have to restrict himself in life
from the things he was doing before for
the sake of Allah so much you know but
to be honest all of those things you're
restricting yourself from it's all
positive anyway oh no I never have to
drink great I hate hangovers I hate
alcohol yeah or you know there's no you
know premarital superficial sex great
that's a massive waste of time anyway
where's the negative really yeah it's
all it's all overwhelmingly positive it
really is and that's why that's why I'm
genuinely grateful to I mean well I'm 40
years old now to find Islam now when I
have the the time to really devote to it
it's great if I found it 10 years ago
maybe I wouldn't had time because it
just would have been I need that money
I'm worried about not being able to
provide for my family now in a position
where I can say you know what work is
great and all but there's more
meaningful stuff to do so I think it
comes to you when when the time is right
I really believe that absolutely
absolutely Allah is the best of planners
right we leave it up to heaven I like
that yeah any final comments Brothers
what would love to would love to do this
again with you I feel like this is one
of our longest podcasts I think in
person this was definitely our longest
podcast but it doesn't feel long enough
to be honest but it doesn't feel long
enough at all it feels like we could
just keep going yeah but unfortunately
our equipment cannot handle this handle
this heat so we're gonna have to wrap it
up right preparation prevents piss poor
performance that's okay correct correct
correct
you guys need bigger SD cards let's do
it let's order it right now this is
Dubai we can order it 24 7.
that's it that's it happens so my
question to you guys is what's the next
Global Conquest tour who are you
traveling to speak with I've got
thankfully I've got some relationships
who are the the people you want on your
podcast you haven't got what's what's
next what's the steps for Global
Conquest because just having intent
isn't enough what are the direct
actionable steps that can be taken hello
I think first and foremost there's a lot
of self-investment that needs to be done
us improving our interviewing skills are
probably just talking about this our
podcasting skills our knowledge on Islam
our knowledge on the world you know
being able to articulate our thoughts
correctly awesome we need to correct
ourselves in these things and fix
ourselves and grow in these uh these
Realms and on that Tate's ability to
speak is a muscle he built over many
years yeah it is it is the ability to to
be eloquent to put forward your ideas in
a concise impactful way it's a skill
that takes many years of work so I'm
glad that you've conceptualized that
that's something you'll focus on and may
Allah you know make us a masters of this
craft and master you know master or
Raiders as Mohammed hijab says I mean
and then after that I think we have to
talk about it we spoke about Habib
inshallah one day we want to talk to
Aiden Ross I've been trying I think we
really need to get in contact with with
Myron with Aiden Ross with snico with uh
speed with Judy on we really need to go
could you guys stay a few days longer
because a number of those guys will be
in Dubai I know they're coming
you can't move
wasn't if it wasn't a religious
pilgrimage we wouldn't mind bro it's a
pretty good reason we wouldn't mind it's
the only good reason I'll give you
because anything else Habibi will sing
in Dubai and also also cultural law
right like Allah allowed us to Planet at
this time this is what he wrote maybe
there's a better time for them to be
contacted by exactly I'm always going to
come back now that we have no good
contact here everyone you listed on that
list I I could I could get in touch with
yeah it's amazing amazing
that's easier of course that one's easy
because also when I brief them on what
you guys are about what you're doing the
fact that again the door before we
started that's pure if we want to talk
about someone's intent driving their
actions that's pure you guys said a
prayer may you may you speak clearly may
your words be positively impactful on
the world I tell Andrew something like
that bang full support easy easy because
in a world of clout chases in a world of
people trying to take his value he
really respects men who are loyal and
and devout to their faith to their path
to their mission so yeah that's an easy
sell that that's that's a two second
decision for Andrew that'll happen and
that that'll when he comes out man he's
going to have some impact
and of course a lot of that is is going
to be in the Islamic context because
again the one book he has inside
I mean if we want to talk about
Allah I mean could this be a way of of
Andrew becoming more devout I believe it
is
I want to add to that because at one
point I saw this video where Andrew said
that he doesn't really read he doesn't
read much like a book he says it's very
slow way to uh get knowledge and he'd
rather have like that real experience
and talking with people who have had
those experiences so he can learn from
them as well and it's like in Islam
we're actually
we are told to read by Allah Allah tells
us to read and to learn for ourselves to
seek the answers for ourselves and I
don't I'm not saying that he wasn't
reading the Quran anything like that but
it's like
Elizabeth
and you know like here he is now nothing
else to do pretty amazing and to give
you an idea into Andrew's like Andrew
will be working on a computer
while
um
like you know it's typing away while
playing chess
while listing the voice notes from
people and responding them while having
a conversation with someone his brain is
like all the time for him to slow down
and read one book
that that had been almost dropping down
that frequency that he's at but again to
your point that's all he can do now he
had the most active phone addiction I've
ever seen because that's how he gets his
message out that's how he makes his
money he now doesn't have a phone
so that ferocious Focus I would bet
significant amounts of money
is betting Halal maybe I should reframe
that I'm highly confident that he is
taking that and let's be honest he's an
obsessive person when it comes to
learning to Conquest that's and most of
the highly successful people I know they
are obsessive they are naturally they
have almost addictive personalities but
they've focused that Obsession on
self-improvement on Conquest on learning
he is that guy
you know to the nth degree
I'm highly confident if not sure that he
is now obsessing over the Quran because
there's nothing else in there and then
we want to talk about Allah being the
best of planners that's probably the
only way you could get him to really
focus on the Quran is to take away his
phone and his ability to to conquer the
world you know it's pretty amazing stuff
the prophet saws he said when Allah
loves a person and wolves for them to be
better you know and and to have a higher
status in this life and the next he
tests them and Allah he says in the
Quran uh
uh that's a taxi
the police are our friends you don't
have to work
but a lot
the police are amazing here brother
honestly like it's every interaction
I've had with law enforcement in this
country has been nothing but wow what
what a what a man taking care of his
society and taking pride in his work
it's beautiful that's what it should be
that's what yeah
but yeah back to the uh back to the
point Allah he says indeed after
hardship is ease and some Scholars say
that the only way that Allah puts you
from a place of difficulty or a lower
status to a higher status or just from
one place to an easier place the only
way Allah moves you is with the
difficulty the Allah will only put you
to a better place by putting you through
something difficult it can come up more
sharpened yeah isn't that the truth and
that's why I'm not worried about the
tights at all I am zero percent worried
about them one because I know who they
are who they aren't I know like they
know what they have and haven't done so
they're not worried so what you're gonna
you are you gonna put them in a Cell
these these advice yeah thank you these
guys have been through so much tension
and stress and
that you want to talk about fire blood
they had such a hunger to take
themselves from Council Council estate
like they were actually in homeless
shelters they were physically hungry
they built an Empire through fighting
through hand-to-hand combat like these
guys have been through so much if they
if they were Pro the narrative
that the world would love them mixed
race kids who built themselves from you
know Council housing who now retired
their mother who now take care of
numerous families who now are putting a
positive message out into the world if
they weren't speaking against the
narrative these guys would be modern day
heroes and that platform that they built
um husna's university that is enabling
many hundreds of thousands as I
understand of people around the world to
generate a second income and when you're
walking around with them in the street
you get people coming up hey man
Hustlers University changed my life here
I bought this car or hey you know my mom
doesn't have to work the media won't
show that but again if these guys were
like leftist soy boys then the world
would love them because what they're
doing is incredible it's incredibly
motivating this hustle's University
thing from talking to some of the guys
involved there'll be like tens of
thousands of guys hustling all right
break push-ups back onto it you know hey
we you know where have you been playing
video games you know they're they're
holding the masculine accountability
they're holding hundreds of thousands of
you know young people to that it's
amazing to see so again everything
they're doing is so positive
don't worry about them and their message
and and Allah's intent
for them the Tates are fine this is
their path this is their Redemption Arc
watch in a year's time in two years time
how positive this whole thing will have
been for making them even more impactful
as men more focused on what matters and
not focused on what doesn't and also
giving them even more influence with
which to put their positive message out
to the world everything is happening as
it should yeah I got one last question
for you please wrap up do you think he
knows that you're Muslim
yes how because I told him that I pray
in the Masjid every day for him that was
the one thing that I said that's the one
thing I said but also like we were
talking about it for a long time I know
he got a little bit viral for using the
word haram I'd like to take a little bit
of credit in perhaps encouraging that
because I mean I've been
probably excessively using that word for
some time now
and so I'd like to think that that might
have rubbed off on him but he and I both
knew that it was it was the way for a
long time and to your point I think you
you
perhaps become Muslim in your beliefs
before you really take that step
formally and we we felt drawn to the
mosque we felt drawn to the Brotherhood
we felt you know interested and curious
about the Quran about the life of the
prophet
Allah
well before we took shahada and so yeah
he's not surprised alhamdulillah yeah
it's uh you basically you accept it in
your heart first before you speak it
into existence it makes sense there's
the heart again I love it brother I love
it got this big masculine beard but
talking about the heart it's beautiful
man I love it it's beautiful and also
the one conversation I had with Tate
about because when I didn't know he was
planning to to revert
um and you know the internet sort of
blew up I know Tate I know if he does it
he's serious so there was no any
question is it real is it not I said
Andrew why why did you make that
decision yeah and his answer was because
there is zero downside and only only
plus only positives
and that was that was I was like yeah
cool that was the extent of our
conversation about his conversion
favorite version zero downside only
positives
and that's true anyone who's been
through that process can attest to that
absolutely we've had we've had many
rivers come on the show and basically
say the same exact thing you know that
Allah when they were blessed with that
slam their life completely changed for
the better every every single River
would tell you the same thing amazing
just by not being able to drink and
being able to say to Tristan sorry mate
can't do it that's going to add 10 years
to my life I swear
because who's the king again we're very
competitive guys he was the king of
making everybody drink and he doesn't
feel alcohol it's it's it's it's it's
inhuman the way he can drink so simply
by not drinking I'm gonna live five to
ten years longer spending time around
Christian so again it's all positive
all right excellent what about the big
fella anything more from you brother
let's do it properly coach
it's okay perfect timing okay so welcome
back I'm here again alhamdulillah
um so I just want to say I think that's
covering your face though if you should
put it I just want to say alhamdulillah
as you guys see this is an amazing
podcast an amazing episode with some
amazing Brothers alhamdulillah we're
going to end it the way it should be
ended with the recitation of the
Glorious Quran and I just want to let
you guys know if you guys have never had
the opportunity to open up the Quran
please take out the opportunity to open
the Quran the Quran is the most recited
book in the world today and it is the
most recited book in the world for a
reason please just open up your heart
and open up your mind and take out the
opportunity to just read the book this
is a book that came to open up your mind
and open up your heart and to share the
truth with you about your Creator and
about yourself so inshallah we're going
to go ahead and end it with some Quran
recitation inshallah
foreign
[Music]
I had I'm so grateful for Islam I'm so
grateful to Allah and I'm so grateful
for my brothers man
bro that's how we leave it so we end it
insha Allah W stream guys make sure you
like comment subscribe follow me with
that being said
may Allah free our brother Andrew Tate
and his brother Tristan Tate from jail
blessed Brothers Tristan with Islam and
make us leaders for the righteous and
with that being said
and they broke before we get back in the
podcast we've got a very special
announcement as you can see we are here
in Masjid
father Muslim Brothers
game we have our first drop coming out
soon we have 200 pieces that are going
to be released within this drop so if
that's something you're trying to do
then click the link on the screen in the
description box down below to get 10 off
on the drop day which is March 31st and
make sure to check your email box so you
can see if you got the message check
your spam folder as well to see if you
got the message that way you can be on
point and be notified as soon as we
release this clothing on March 31st
percent of all proceeds are going to
building a Masjid in Norway so make sure
that you are checking your email so that
you can confirm and be notified when we
drop on March 31st collection is going
to be called Victory impatience in honor
of Andrew and Tristan Tate for what
they're going through right now so let's
make Dua so that Allah releases them as
soon as possible and brings them out in
the best state that he can possibly
bring them out in and with that being
said let's get right back into the
podcast
foreign